Oh,
a lot of this shit's in your head,
man.
Let it go and if you do let it go to
my website and in the code name Rogan,
and you get 15% off when you click
on the link for the flashlight.
Oh,
there you go.
We're also sponsored by Onnit,
O n n I t.com.
The makers of Alpha brain,
a cognitive enhancing
supplement and new mood,
a five HTP supplement that
actually boosts your mood.
You know,
it's a funny thing about
this new mood stuff,
but people who are on antidepressants,
their doctors are telling them not to
take five HTP because they say it's like
taking two antidepressants,
which is really fascinating to me because
that means that this natural vitamin
is actually an antidepressant.
I don't know enough to comment on it.
Maybe Bruce slipped and he'll help
us out once we get this podcast.
Absolutely rolling.
We're also the makers of shroom tech,
which is a quarter [inaudible]
mushroom endurance supplement,
which is wicked.
If you work out hard,
if you don't want to work out really hard,
don't bother with this.
But if you're someone who does anything
like really difficult and you know,
football or wrestling or Jujitsu
or something like really strenuous,
like Mrs Rogan likes it
and she's in a cycling,
you know,
if you get on this stuff,
it really does give you like
a nice little endurance boost.
You feel it's good stuff.
Yeah.
I don't appreciate it based on science.
I don't,
nothing.
Nothing.
Right.
There's no reason for me to
take any of that shit at all.
Now you're completely sedentary.
Now I'm good at or I lasagna tech.
You're very happy being sedentary though.
A lot of people would say they're like,
this kid is in denial and he really
wants to know your fucking fine with it.
Right.
And there is the less uh,
activity I have to do the better.
You're like a turtle.
You are.
That's why I chose were so long.
That's right.
You know,
I heard something,
I don't know if it's true,
but that every animal essentially from
the moment it's born to the moment dies
of old age,
has the same amount of
heartbeats like are very similar.
At least,
you know.
And so like you only have a certain
amount of heartbeats and like no
professional athlete has ever
lived to be more than a hundred.
Yeah.
Her feet,
you'll burn your body out.
You're,
you're going nutty.
Me.
You,
you'll be around to the fucking Martians.
Come back to people on
cold weather live longer.
That's a good question.
I don't know.
Cold weather,
like make her heart beat
slower because you're real.
I would think that you use some way too
many resources and cold weather to just
try to stay alive.
Oh yeah.
You shiver [inaudible] acids going nutty.
Anyway.
Uh,
so shroom tech now for you Brian,
but you can benefit from new
mood and from brain and no,
this ain't like,
it's not like something
from the movie limitless.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
It's not gonna make you
smarter if you're stupid,
but it does make you know,
like a lot of different substances too.
They're called nootropics
and they actually can give
you like a little bit of a
mental boost,
research it.
And as I always say,
if you're interested in this stuff and
we think what we sell is too expensive,
go online and steal the recipe,
steal the recipe and go buy your
stuff in bulk and save some money.
And if you like,
and I hope she,
I hope you do.
I hope it helps you.
You don't have to buy our stuff,
but if you want to buy our stuff,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and turn the
code name rogue and get 10% off.
All right,
freaks.
Have we got that out of
the way through slips?
Isn't that Bruce Lipton's excuse me.
Their symptom is in the house.
Hit the wind.
I don't know when a cow,
she doesn't ask [inaudible]
with a serious man hair.
Can we get our shit together?
Bruce Lipton,
the author of the biology of belief and a,
we're going to learn some shit today.
Freaks.
Cause I talked to Bruce Lipton for about
30 seconds before this podcast started
and I already was like too anxious to get
the commercials out of the way because
I,
this is a a fascinating,
fascinating subject to me and you are a
guy who actually has like letters next
to your name.
So like people are gonna listen to you.
It says Phd,
this guy that was the
fuck he's talking about,
right?
It's not like when I,
if I write a book,
the biology of belief,
Joe,
Joe Rogan,
comedian,
a fear factor.
I was,
nobody's going to give a fuck.
All right,
but you,
you sir,
you command respect with your eyes.
I tell you,
I am the happiest guy ever because
all of this stuff was new to me.
I never believed in it when
I was doing my research.
So to find out things like,
like the concept of a spirit and an energy
and a and how the mind controls life.
When I was teaching genes
control life and it was like,
boy,
is that an error or is
that wrong out there?
So consciousness,
you believe control slides,
I believe consciousness actually does
control life and it's very simple to
understand it.
And what you really start
to find out is that,
uh,
our consciousness either enhances
us like a placebo effect or the same
consciousness can take away
your strength and kill you.
What,
which is called a no CBO effect.
And it's actually a name for that.
So it's the power of your thinking
and the thinking is who are we?
And,
and we've been programmed to believe
that we're frail and vulnerable,
you know,
like all kinds of things are out
there to get us and we have to protect
ourselves and all that.
And it's like this is a totally insane
because we are so powerful that we even
don't believe it.
It's just,
it's just amazing things like,
okay,
you can say something simple
like walking across hot coals.
Okay.
It's like you can walk across hot
coals if you believe you can do it,
but you can't do it if you don't believe.
You can't walk across the coals.
And so belief comes into it.
Or Joe,
you,
I mean you're a big health
guy and all this stuff.
So I asked you,
can you,
if we go out here in the parking lot,
can you lift up a car?
I mean you got a lot of
training and stuff like that,
but you think you could lift up a car?
No.
Well,
interesting.
So many articles from around the world
about women lifting up cars when a,
when a baby or their child
is trapped under the car.
And this is all true cause stories too,
but I never really googled them.
No,
no,
they're,
they're absolutely true in
those large numbers of them.
And what does that mean?
It means like this untrained unathletic
woman could go out there and lift up the
car.
Ah,
okay.
And so that's like,
that's pretty neat.
But here's when I really think is cool.
Um,
down south there,
those baptist fundamentalist
kind of people that get into,
in a religious ecstasy state,
and they do what they called
testify that God protects them.
So they believe that God protects them.
And so what did they do?
They do strange crap,
like a handle snakes like
rattlesnakes and copperhead snakes.
There's they Candler's so
they get bitten by the snakes.
Nothing happens when they're in
this and the state of a belief.
But that's,
those are the light waste.
The serious ones.
So the ones they drink strychnine
in toxic doses to demonstrate,
to show the proof that God protects them.
They drink this absolute poison,
no harmful effects.
Wow.
No harmful effects,
Brian.
And it's the most,
I mean,
they're insane looking
people when they do it,
but the fact is they drink poison,
but it's in the belief system.
So this is all stuff
that's been documented,
right?
Yeah.
Your initial background as a scientist,
what did you uh,
I trained as a cell biologist and um,
um,
I started doing cell cultures back.
I'm stem cells in 1967 and I was like,
that's so long ago.
That was 40 some years ago.
Right?
And the thing was there
was just a handful of us,
the entire world working
on stem cells at that time.
And the results from those studies were
so completely different than what I was
teaching medical students
about how life worked,
about how genes control life,
because it showed the genes
did not control the biology.
Genes do not control it.
The control is how a cell or an
organism responds to the environment.
So it's a,
the,
an organism becomes a compliment
to their environment and you say,
well,
why is that important?
I said,
well,
if you'll live in a crappy environment
than your biology becomes crap.
And the issue is,
is that the real environment,
it's actually the mental environment.
So that's why it's so important
and everyone sort of knows this,
but it's so important to surround
yourself with positive people and not be
around a bunch of energy vampires because
there's people that are caught in a
downward spiral.
And if you were with them,
they're gravity can bring
you into a shitty place.
That's an absolute truth.
That's a quantum quantum
physics aspect to or who we are.
There's more than this
physical reality and,
and an energy is actually who we are.
So the flow of energy
determines how we are.
Isn't it funny though,
that that idea so easily dismissed?
It seems like such a woowoo idea.
Oh,
I can tell you why.
It's more scared of it.
It's money.
Well,
it's also fear that,
well,
it might be fear,
but I'll tell you more.
So is
very simply the science that we have in
the textbooks today is more or less a
product of paid advertising
from the pharmaceutical
company and the significance
why mean that is the,
let me ask you questions all day.
Obviously.
Are you aware there's much more effective
ways to create energy besides burning
fossil fuel?
I mean,
you know,
I'm not really aware of all
the options that there are,
aren't there?
I mean,
I'm,
I mean solar and all
this other kind of stuff.
I mean,
I know about solar,
but I don't know if so unnecessarily
generate enough energy to replace it right
now.
Well,
that's our technology.
But the question is,
we have all this new
technology and the question is,
why are we still so preoccupied
with burning fossil fuel?
Because it's not in the interest of the
petroleum company to support anything
that would take away the
sale of their product.
They sell oil.
What good is it?
And then I say,
now here's the exact parallel.
It's like you can heal
yourself with energy.
You can heal yourself with thoughts,
you can hear yourself with
the right vibrational food
and everything else around
it by dealing with the vibration park.
So he said,
well,
we know this for a thousand years.
Why?
Why isn't it recognized by the world?
And the answer is it's not in the
interest of an industry that sells drugs.
Because if I can heal you for free,
then what are you going to
do with the drug market?
Do you think that's,
I mean,
do you think they're suppressing it or
do you think there's just never been any
evidence demonstrated that I'm like I
on any sort of a large measurable level
where there's,
there's quite a bit of evidence,
but it's really evidence that's not
talked about in the public and it's very
difficult.
I'm sure there is,
but what I mean is it's not like it's
in their face and they're trying to
suppress it.
You know what I mean?
I think it's just,
I think a lot of people are
just ignorant to the idea.
I don't know if it's being suppressed
as much as just a lot of people really
don't know how things work.
I absolutely,
absolutely,
but then the limitation of
what are we being program with,
you know,
what are the beliefs that you wrote
blues did you get program with about your
life for very simple reason.
If you get down to the
simple understanding how your
mind controls your genetics
and your biological behavior,
then you have to recognize them.
The question is what programs
have you been programmed with?
Because those are the programs
are going to shape your life.
And the belief system is,
Ken,
can you drink strychnine Joe,
yes or no?
The answer is,
well,
if you don't believe you
can then don't go there.
You now,
or if you have any doubts
at all the belief like that,
it's like pregnancy.
You either believe it
or you don't believe it,
but there's no like,
Geez,
I'm,
I almost really believed
this is not gonna work.
So you think it's fascinating that a
lot of the people that are pushing that
belief are actually,
they actually are caught
up in it themselves.
You know the people that
are suppressing information.
Yes.
People that are,
you know,
they,
even if they're aware of it,
yes.
You know,
they're actually,
they're doing it to themselves as well.
That's the,
that's why you can't say there's
a conspiracy at some level.
No,
that's not a conspiracy.
There's self interest.
This is my interest.
This is my belief.
Look,
there are a lot of religious people out
there trying to shape my behavior today.
Right,
right.
It's like that's their behavior.
You know,
they're trying to shape my behavior.
Whether it's sort of like the science
people that tell their science or almost
like religious people that say this
is our story and the fact that shit,
but there's a bigger story
than what you saw in the book.
And so was it just that
it's not measurable?
I mean,
well,
no,
it's measurable.
I can show you a hundreds of papers on
all kinds of things about electromagnetic
fields that vibrational fields can do
control every function of the cell.
They can control the synthesis of DNA.
It can control the cell division.
It can control what we call
differentiation where uh,
uh,
like an embryonic cell becomes
a muscle cell or a bone cell.
It controls the organization of cells.
There are demonstrations
of this all the time,
vibrational frequencies with the exact
frequencies cause cells to have very
specific biological responses.
So if it was up to you,
would this be something that they would
be teaching kids in school like on a,
on a regular basis to try to
explain absolutely very early age,
how important it is to think in a positive
way and absolutely in a positive way.
And surround yourself
with positive people,
that it's not just a
luxury that you're looking,
oh,
I just want to settle down.
It'd be around,
you know where it's quiet.
It's not that,
but it actually is like you
can establish your environment.
You have comes down with simple point.
We are creating this life that's
in front of us at this moment.
This is a creation and a,
and this is a nature of
what quantum mechanics,
quantum mechanics came up with
a very simple problem and say,
wait,
is the fundamental particle
that makes an atom?
Is it physical or is it vibrational?
Is it a particle like,
like a piece of something or
is it just a vibrational field?
And the answer came out
because it can't be both.
One solid.
The other one's an energy wave,
right?
It's like,
and yet it comes out when
they did the experiment.
If you think it's a particle and you
design the experiment to see a particle,
you see a particle.
If you think it's a wave and design
an experiment to determine a wave,
then you see it as a wave.
And the question of,
well,
how can it be a wave and a particle?
They there,
they're there.
You can't be both at the same time.
The conclusion of the physicists,
and this is fundamental,
is that it's The observer
that determining that reality.
It's the way you look at it.
If you look at it like an old Fart,
does that go?
Does it go [inaudible] and you know
ultimately attacks being so we created,
well this is a co participation,
so we're really,
we're creating,
but we're also participating in the
creation so it's not a single van.
I maybe there's a single vendor.
I say,
okay,
and hey,
let's send all this roar and crap and
let's clean up this place that's have a
good time.
My voice is a single voice.
Obviously just didn't change anything.
But if you get enough
voices say the same thing,
then what you're doing is
you're amplifying the field.
The more people that are in
tune with the same voice,
it becomes a crowd response.
It's like,
even like in Soccer Games in
Europe when they get crazy,
they,
they always break out into these
big fights and stuff like that.
A pacifist
sitting in the middle,
you know,
what are those vegan pacifist
guys sitting in the middle?
If there's a fight that
breaks out all around,
they'll be caught up in the energy of
a crowd response and it won't be their
consciousness that's controlling them.
Then now they're just caught in the field
and they will pick up a chair in club,
somebody over the head with it.
Like anybody else in that field.
Even though at that moment when they
were being conscious they were pacifists.
But once they got caught in the field,
that became part of the field.
So the issue is what field are we living
in right now in the field is in a state
of flux.
And this is really critical,
uh,
because your audience is so involved
with this upheaval that's happening right
now,
changing the fields that,
uh,
there's an evolution going on and it
really is going to be a fine subdivision
between like the forties and
unders and the people over 40.
I think you're going to be
a separation at some point,
except there are a lot of
wonderful old people like myself,
old people.
Uh,
do you think the Internet has anything
to do with the Internet age group at the
Internet?
The Internet has everything to do with it.
The Internet is the nervous
system of a new service,
a new organism.
And what's evolving?
Here's what's important.
Sometimes we think,
oh,
when humans evolve with it,
how are they going to be involved with,
are going to get bigger heads?
And,
uh,
you know,
change their bodies.
It's like,
no,
no.
Look,
the human evolved that's done.
Cockroach evolved.
The cockroach involves
600 million years ago.
It's still the same cockroach.
The human evolve.
It's going to stay the same human.
The evolution is not of the human.
It's of the community of humans.
Each human is the equivalent of a cell
in the body of a super organism called
humanity.
The evolution is the evolution,
Manny.
That's why the Arab spring,
that's why the breakdown of
politics all over the place.
That's why the thing falling apart.
People all over the world are recognizing
we're all people and the same thing
called humanity and and so we have to
break free of the limitations that we have
been programmed with.
And in that breaking free,
which means changing the thoughts,
changing the beliefs,
getting into a new understanding,
we are on the threshold of a,
an evolution that's so amazing.
And what's interesting is that people
look around right now they're scared to
death and I'd go and you don't understand,
this is the most important stage.
The simple reason is this.
The institutions that have
provided for us up to this point,
they help get us here.
They were important for a period of time.
Uh,
economics,
education,
healthcare,
politics,
religion,
all those things were helpful to
get to this to a certain point.
Now they're destructive because their
belief systems and having us destroy the
planet.
So a as a,
this is a simple fact that this is not,
I'm just saying,
it is a fact.
Science has recognized we are deep into
the six mass extinction of life on this
planet.
Five times in the history of this planet,
life got essentially wiped out
and started all over again.
Those are called mass extinctions such
as like a common or asteroid hitting the
planet,
destroying the environment,
wiping out life.
Start all over again.
This is the sixth one.
This is a fact.
We are losing species of organisms faster
than recorded history or unrecorded
history.
As we know right now,
meaning we're accelerating the
loss of the biosphere right now.
Why is this important?
Is because we're part of that extinction.
And now here's the neat part about it.
The source of our extinction
is human behavior.
Simple as that.
We are so undermining the environment.
We,
uh,
we were created from the environment.
You know,
religious people will tell you,
oh,
they created an environment and they
stuck humans on top genesis kind of story.
Scientists will say,
oh,
it was just an accident of
genetics mutations that were here.
And it's like,
no,
every organism was an integral part
of the evolution of a larger con.
The biosphere is the living organism.
We're part of it.
Well,
if we're part of the biosphere
were derived from the biosphere,
then this is a simple logical question.
If you destroy the biosphere,
what they all are,
your chances of surviving
and the answer's no.
And that's exactly what
science has shown us,
that we are now have passive,
a very critical point.
And destroying the environment,
threatening our own survival.
I mean the simple fact that scary,
if you think about it,
within 30 years there will be no fish in
the ocean at the rate we're going right
now.
It's like that's almost
like science fiction story.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
So why is it important?
Because the conclusion as
human behavior is causing it.
And Einstein,
he had a great saying.
I said,
you can't solve the problems with the
same thinking that created the problems of
the institutions that we are living
by today or the cause of the problem.
So the crash of the institutions is
unnecessary step in the evolution because
you can't build a sustainable world.
And those belief systems,
they're the,
they're the systems that are causing the
destruction of the environment that we
live in.
Now.
Do you ever consider the
possibility that all behavior,
all life on this planet is,
is natural and that there's a reason
why people are so selfish and so
destructive and yet so also so
ambitious and so prone to technological,
uh,
you know,
creations and,
and,
and pushing,
pushing things forward.
It's almost like,
it's almost like that's
what we're supposed to do.
It's a strange thing.
It's almost like to be as ambitious as
people are to create for technological
innovation is like the,
there today,
they're,
they're announcing that they may have
spotted the Higgs Boston park or Boson
particle.
They may have spot it.
They don't know.
They have like evidence
they have to go over.
I mean this is,
this is right at the,
at the peak of human innovation.
It seems like,
it almost seems like we have to be
this fucked up to do it this way.
You know?
And this is what we're driven to do.
Do you,
is that possible that it seems like
every other animal has like a natural
pattern of behavior.
Is it possible that the human animals
natural pattern of behavior is to almost
like give birth to some
technological creation?
Okay.
There's two parts to that question.
The answer to technological innovation
is indeed the evolution process itself.
Think about this.
Um,
we have a tendency when we're humans to
look down at everything less than human
is not being as intelligent.
Right?
And then I'm going to tell you,
you're made out of 50
trillion cells like Amoebas,
50 trillion Amoebas,
living in a community.
They created a technology
to make a human body.
They created technology.
We named as did the Amoebas,
did they?
They created the structure for us.
The body was created by,
by the cells.
Okay?
We can't even reproduce the technology
of the cells because they're far greater
efficient than we are.
Matter of fact,
that would be our direction of
evolutions is to see what they've done.
But why is this important?
Because the technology's
part of the evolution.
The idea of technology as
simple can we live in the,
so called,
you know,
if you want to use like a garden of Eden
that there was a garden here before we
destroyed it.
And in fact he's uh,
you know,
uh,
if you want to live in the garden
without destroying the garden,
technology's a requirement because it
reduces the footprint so we can live here
without devastating the
environment around us.
Okay.
So that technology is a built in drive.
Is the behavior that we're
expressing during this part of that?
No,
the behaviors programmed.
What you're talking about is the
manifestation of Darwinian theory as a
scientific fact,
which it isn't,
but it,
but what's the base is theory says
life is a struggle for survival with a
competition for fitness.
And what does it mean is that every day
you go out there and struggle a beat?
The other guy.
Why?
Because the co this theory says if
you don't struggle with the other guy,
they'll be you.
So you have to beat them first.
And that's,
we've been playing that
game for since Darwin.
Right.
And that's the competition game.
That's the competition
game and the garden was,
if you think about it,
a garden doesn't survive by competition.
The garden a supervised by cooperation.
As a matter of fact,
that's what the evolution is all about.
Cooperation in the biosphere and we're
the most uncooperative life form in the
garden.
Isn't the argument to that,
that the competition is
what breeds the innovation?
Um,
well that's why I said that I don't
know and I don't want to say yes or no,
but I will say this,
that there was a good reason for living
this way to a certain point because it
got us to a certain point,
right?
But continuing that process is
where the problem comes from.
You see that that is the,
the recognition of that is why the whole
human race seems to be like putting the
brakes right now on this
conventional culture,
putting the brakes and this can decide
society that we've accepted up to this
point.
It doesn't seem like people
won't accept it anymore.
It seems like people were sustainable.
Yeah,
they're,
they're seeing that it's ridiculous and
they're seeing that our leaders aren't
really leading us.
And I seen that everyone seems to be
bought and paid off and everyone's hitting
the brakes.
Everyone's going,
stop,
stop this thing.
Stop it.
Yeah.
Because it's time to build something
that that takes into consideration.
Not the,
the few that possesses the power.
You see,
look,
we can talk about,
when I talk about the biology and the
nature of the mind controlling the
behavior in the biology,
women lifting,
cars,
drinking,
strychnine,
the powerful nature you are.
Do we know what actually physically,
when is it adrenaline?
What is the actual physical thing that
happens to their body that allows them to
do amazing things?
It's exactly the same thing that,
uh,
the strychnine drinker has absolute
belief that there's no Mike child is under
this car.
There's not even a concept though.
Can I lift the car?
She never asked that in her head it was,
I'm lifting the car because
my babies under the car.
It's absolute belief is the same
as walking across the hot coals,
the drinking district,
nine lifting the car,
the things you have that
absolute belief in you.
You can do powerful things beyond
anything except that's where I said,
go back and look at our programming.
Our programming is we've been programmed
to perceive ourselves as frail and
vulnerable,
in fact,
were farthest thing from
that except for this,
and this is an interesting story about
the upheaval and that goes like this.
You look at the world and you say,
look,
am I powerful?
Maybe.
Okay,
I'm not so powerful.
Boy,
there's some very powerful people
over there and then you may say,
well,
how did they get to be so powerful?
This is the joke and it's on us.
They didn't get more powerful.
They just took away the power from us.
We've been programmed to be disempowered
and the fact is that's what you think.
This has been a conscious thing.
It's been propagated.
Look,
but I'll give you,
here's a fact.
Think about it this way.
The Jesuits have boasted for 500 years.
They said,
give me a child until it's six or seven
and it will belong to the church for the
rest of their lives.
What did they know?
They already knew that if I get
the first six years of programming,
I own your life.
They knew that they boasted about it.
And why is that important?
Well,
it's,
you think that's a minor thing that just
would have slipped away in history that
you can control the population
by programming the first
six years of their lives
to think is,
are you kidding me?
That's,
that's fundamental to
the leadership of the,
of whoever's in leadership capacity.
Uh,
and,
and if you want to reference,
think about this.
There's a book rich Dad,
Poor Dad,
and this is a book about power,
empowerment and disempowerment.
And what's the point?
People from poor families will grow up
and remain poor and people from rich
families will generally
grow up and remain rich.
Is it genetics?
No,
it's the programming that the
rich give to their family,
which is completely the
opposite of the programming.
The poor give to their family.
It's not the individual,
it's not the person.
It's the programming,
and this is not new.
This is 500 years of boasting.
That fact.
Not much.
I mean,
they didn't keep it a secret.
They actually said this,
you just give me the kit for six years,
belongs to the church
for the rest of its life.
They knew.
It's kind of like this whole,
this whole theory.
I'm sorry,
I'm gonna interrupt you real quick.
It's really fucking loud.
None other room,
man.
It's picking up on this.
Mike and Matt stirred.
That's,
I mean it sounds fine,
but you don't hear it.
It wasn't a distracting.
It's distracting me.
Turned on in your headphones or
your headphones are really loud.
How do we do that?
But I follow the string.
The whole thing with it
kind of follows the uh,
uh,
fish and the fish tank or like
how big is the fish tank and how,
how big the fish is going to grow almost.
It's like kind of the same thing.
You know,
like we're like in some ways like it,
the fish nose is a environment,
so it's going to grow.
I mean,
does it have anything
to do with that at all?
It was basically they know their world
and they read their world and we're
having problems recognizing our own world.
We,
we've been programmed not to
be sensitive to the experience.
That's why indigenous people,
the Indians,
so the aborigines,
all these people,
man,
they can tell you what the water is.
Even if you can't see it,
it's under the ground that they can
tell you what's going on in their world
around them.
We are so disconnected.
We have no idea,
but how did this happen?
Do you think that this is a natural
occurrence is you think that this was that
this all happened because this is
the way we would be so innovative.
This is the way we would push forward,
push forward regardless of the health and
safety of each other and of the planet
itself.
Yeah.
It's an unfortunate situation
because you have to go back and say,
when did,
when did this group of individuals,
which is another large group at that
decided at one point they were helping us
as parents.
I'm helping you guys.
I know more
than you so I'm going to,
I'm going to help you become better.
Okay,
but there is a point where
maybe their knowledge is not,
it's so limited that they,
they're thinking inside the box when
the knowledge is outside the box.
So the question is is it a conspiracy
because they want to control this.
There was a conspiracy not as such,
but like a parent saying,
look that people don't know
what the hell they're doing.
We got to help them.
We've got to guide them and all that.
It's a tossup.
Was this conspiracy or helping?
I have no,
you know all ideas this they're
involved with either either of those two
reasons.
They are the problem that we have right
now because their thinking is not up to
the current awareness
of science and you said,
well why is that relevant?
The answer is simple.
It's like the world we live in,
cs truth based on weather
science says it's true or not.
This is true.
Oh Science said over Yo,
it must be true.
Well,
if the science is limited
then the knowledge is power,
lack of knowledge,
lack of power.
If the science is not fully knowledgeable
and limits it to that little narrow
knowledge,
then we've limited our power and the fact
is there's new science that undermines
all this stuff that you learned in school.
All this stuff I taught in medical school
that sciences in the last 15 years,
man is a revolution and the
revolution is the rebels in the front.
The the,
the old guard is still stolen.
The back where the old textbooks
with outdated information,
it's totally outdated.
Does it become an ego issue at that point
with people are teaching one thing for
their whole life and then
they don't want to change?
I don't know if it's,
it's a habit.
It's a habit.
This is the way I know.
It's the only way I know what I mean.
Look,
there was a time before quantum physics,
the only physicists were the,
the Newtonian physicists,
the ones that only saw the mechanical
material world as real and didn't consider
the invisible realm as anything.
Quantum physics comes in and says it's
the invisible realm that is actually
shaping the physical realm.
Energy shapes matter.
And it's like,
well,
if you're a Newtonian physicists,
up until let's say 1924 and 90 25 the,
the belief change is 1924 year teaching
the world is a mechanical machine.
You've done this for 30 years,
and then all of a sudden,
a few minutes later he say,
no,
guess what?
All that's wrong.
It's all completely different.
And it's like you've spent
your whole career doing this.
What are you going to change tonight?
It's not going to happen.
So what do those guys do?
They just put the perhaps on everything.
They,
they,
they squash it down.
They keep it repressed.
And it's interesting
because I'm so disgusting.
Oh,
Eh,
there's a statement,
there's a statement that the answers
that it says progress in science is
measured tombstone by tombstone.
Wow.
Meaning you have to offer that die
before you can get the new thought.
Amazing.
And it's just the ego,
right?
Absolutely.
And the money nor the money,
the money is big.
The money is,
Healthcare costs,
the United States are sinking the
entire country just on the bells of that
alone.
And that's totally in U Maine.
It's in you mane by by definition it is
and it's a business entity and medicine
is a business entity.
It is not a healing entity.
If you got healed,
the whole business would collapse.
So guess what,
how come with all the money and
all the technological advances,
we're spending more money now than we've
ever done having more healthcare than
we ever had and we have the
sickest population we ever had.
This is the sickest
population we've ever had.
Yeah,
yeah.
The population.
The issue just as to any of us.
Is that what it is?
No,
it's just a we're,
we have been,
we misunderstand how our lives work.
We're think we're,
we're like machines and you go to the
pharmacy guy and he puts a medicine in
there and all of a sudden you've
got some new parts and it's like no,
you there,
there is a part like aspect of your body,
your body's like a vehicle for sure.
But the mind is the driver.
So the driver has been
left out of medicine.
All they talk about is all the
vehicles broken is you know,
keep fixing the vehicles.
Like there's a driver in there.
If the drivers got some
shitty driver education,
man,
he's going to destroy the
vehicle and the answer,
that's where the problem came from.
So is what we're experiencing really
a step in the evolution of
what we're going to become.
And so this,
all this,
this,
these problems and all this is rebellion
against the standard behavior that
we've,
you know,
fed into for so long is all of this
like a step in an evolution to some,
one of the most important steps
in the world for simple reason.
If the institutions that we are living
by now have created the problem,
then there's a simple understanding.
You cannot build a sustainable
future on those institutions.
So you think this is a consciousness dap?
Is that what it,
absolutely,
it's a people waking up to who
they are as people stop being the,
the blind sheep that are being led to
the slaughter every day by those people
who know who they are.
The fact is,
if I program you to be
weak and ineffective,
I program you.
Yeah.
Here's an interesting fact.
Being black in this country
is a totally negative aspect.
They,
they,
they took black students and
that's where I played basketball,
all of this an issue about that too.
But the,
and the,
and that's part of an ass
part of the problem of a,
that's a trade off,
uh,
when,
when you grow up in a
threatening environment,
uh,
the fetus will develop,
um,
uh,
bigger arms and legs and
a much better hindbrain,
uh,
because this is what's
necessary for defense.
Wow.
And if you grow up in a
very loving environment,
then the goes into the forefront of Jelly.
Man.
No,
I agree with that.
They're always trying to
reach for their dreams.
You know,
said they have longer arms.
I like Michael Irvin
actually told me this,
I was on a plane with him once
and he was explaining to me,
you know,
he does,
uh,
a lot of,
you know,
he's a famous football player and
he does a lot of work with kids,
you know,
that uh,
grow up and have like
a lot of anger issues.
And he sort of explained to me that when
you were a baby and you're growing up
inside of a woman's body,
you know,
you're developing in a
horrible environment where
there's no father and his
violence and as you know,
crime and all this,
the fetus will like,
become like programmed to act quicker,
to be more violence to me.
Yeah.
Literally.
Yeah,
that's exactly what the is.
Try to stick them in a fucking
cubicle that this whole thing,
this whole thing is so screwed that way
because then we propagate that and we
say,
look,
well,
okay,
look,
blacks are great athletes.
I said,
yeah,
look where they all come from.
They all come from,
you know,
essentially,
uh,
an environment that is
totally not supportive,
which means biologically they have to
acquire the ability to fight to survive.
So their bodies are designed
much healthier in that regard.
That's pretty crazy
when you think about it.
It's like nature to suppressing of the,
you know,
the,
the black man has made the
black men stronger than,
than the suppressor.
Well,
[inaudible] is a logical,
physical,
physiological sense.
Yes.
Wow.
Because you have to,
they have to struggle to stay alive.
So they're designed to be in struggle.
Is it true that shit that Jimmy the Greek
got fired for when he said that black
people have been bred,
you know,
as slaves,
the biggest ones they would breed
with the other biggest ones.
Is that why so many black people or big
or do you believe that it's a stress and
environment issues?
An environment issue.
Wow.
Totally stretched and environment.
And,
and this is why we have to recognize
biological organisms or designed to be a
compliment to their environment.
So really like boxing promoters,
they should go to like horrible
neighborhoods and scout talent.
Yeah.
Well,
that's the toughest kids in a block are,
aren't they?
Yeah.
So that's what you're going to find them.
So yeah.
Wow.
That's a fascinating statement.
It's fascinating to think that so much
is controlled by environment and by
thinking and by energy.
But we all know that we gravitate
towards those things naturally.
You know,
you gravitate towards good times.
He gravitate towards people
that make you feel good.
You know,
your,
your unconscious drive
is to seek out harmony,
eh,
your vibration.
So first of all,
we see ourselves as physical reality,
but a physical reality is an illusion.
Adams or vibrational units there,
there was no physicality to it.
So you a vibration.
And the significance is when you get
other vibrations that are in harmony with
you,
that's called constructive interference.
That means good vibes.
When you find your itself
with other people that have
the same vibration as you,
your energy gets enhanced.
It's good vibes.
If you find yourself in a
threatening environment,
the energy gets canceled and that's
why you feel all of a sudden drained,
weak.
You feel very vulnerable and it's because
you're in an environment where the
energy of the environment is
not in harmony with who you are.
So organisms unconsciously will move
to environments that strengthens their
vibration.
They'll seek it out.
That's so that's why we're
naturally designed to,
to seek out harmony in the world.
That's,
that's our intention.
If that's our intention,
than why do we do so much destructive
shit because there's conscious intention,
conscious mind,
and this is,
this is the big issue that we have to,
that people have to understand.
The mind has two parts.
There's the conscious part
and the subconscious part.
The conscious part is you,
your personal identity.
It's creative,
it has your wishes and desires.
The subconscious part is like
a record playback mechanism.
It learns experiences,
push the button,
place experiences back.
Okay,
so now I say,
well,
okay,
our personal drivers are conscious,
wish and desire.
And then I'm going to tell you a fact,
and this is the freaky fact.
Science has shown that we only run our
lives 5% of the time with our conscious
mind,
our creative mind,
the mind with your wishes.
And what you want out of life.
95% of our life comes from
the subconscious automated
programs that play when we
don't even pay attention.
You don't.
You can drive the car
without paying attention.
It's an automatic program.
You can do your job
without paying attention.
It's an automatic program.
So why is it important?
Only 5% of our life
comes from what we want.
95% comes from the subconscious programs.
And then here's the catch.
As we mentioned earlier,
the first six years you downloading
behavior from your environment and those
become your fundamental programs.
You Watch your parents,
your family,
your community,
and this is why I said the
church saw that and they said,
give me the first six years,
whatever program I put in that six years
will become the fundamental programs in
the subconscious mind.
The operating system.
That's the basic operating system in 95%
of your life is going to play from that
program.
So who are we?
Whatever we've been programmed to be.
What do you want to be?
Not necessarily the program,
but when you try and
exercise your conscious mind,
like positive thinking,
conscious mind 5% of the time,
as is dealing with so much
unconscious program around,
it's,
it's thinking about the future.
It's thinking about the past.
It's so what do you propose?
Do you propose?
It may be like,
oh,
a standard of thinking be established or
a way of thinking where you teach kids
in school how to overcome like these
subconscious thoughts and how to overcome
this gospel.
You can't,
oh,
absolutely can reprogram
these if you could,
and this would be a crappy world because,
and I say,
well,
that just like James,
oh,
you're stuck with your
programs your whole life.
Sorry.
No,
no,
no.
You can change your programs and change
your life virtually instantaneously,
but you have to know
what you're trying to do.
And that's the whole
idea of nobody knows a,
that they're even behaving from there.
They're unconscious programs.
They don't even believe that.
They think,
oh,
I'm running my life with my
intentions and my wishes.
It's like what they're thinking.
And I say that's 5% but I,
in my lectures I give,
I say to people,
I said,
look,
I know sometime in your life
you had a very close friends,
you knew your friend's behavior and you
happen to know your friend's parent.
And at some point you may have seen
that your friend had some of the same
behavior.
So you,
you volunteered,
you go,
you know bill,
you're just like your dad and the
first guy you back away from his bill,
he's going to go ballistic and say,
how can you compare me to my dad?
And I tell people that that's so
profound a story for what reason.
Here it is.
Everyone else can see that
bill behaves like his dad,
the only one who doesn't see it as bill.
And,
and we're all bill.
Meaning we play behaviors that don't even
harmonize with our wishes and desires.
But when we played them,
we don't see them because they're
automatic and unconscious.
And then we wonder why our life
isn't going where we want it to go.
And we didn't realize fundamentally
we were the ones that we're shooting
ourselves in the foot.
And the first place.
And it's because we didn't understand
that the control can be controlled by the
conscious mind.
But when the conscious
mind's thinking about stuff,
then the default is the subconscious.
But the subconscious
program by other people.
Do you think that people are
starting to realize this?
Because you know,
if you think about it,
like on Twitter,
you'll see people even like
dumb people say something,
you know,
today just going to be all smiles
and they're like Hashtag positivity,
you know,
it's like there's the,
that wouldn't have happened in 1930.
No guy would have left his house with,
you know,
one of those little fucking knit
caps on and shit and positivity.
You know,
they didn't think that Franklin Roosevelt
used to read the Sunday comics to the,
to the,
on the radio to the country
and that depression on Sunday,
he'd read them the comics,
like,
come on man,
it's time to take a break and
laugh and stuff like that.
So,
uh,
he,
he was,
he was the guy that he had the answer we
back then he said this was his motto or
statement.
The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself.
What did he know?
He knew that it was the fear
that will immobilize you,
not the thing you even
were thinking about.
Just having the fear of
something and mobilized issue.
If people have so much control,
if thoughts and ideas and
consciousness has so much control,
what is the,
what's the cause of things
like the Great Depression?
What's the cause of these giant
hiccups in the historical process where
something terrible happens,
like the Holocaust or
something along those lines?
Like what is it?
Is it just,
is it like push and pull?
I mean,
is it that,
is it a natural process of,
of evil and good,
constantly battling it out
so that good does evolve?
I did not sin.
I accomplish that,
that,
that easy to say.
I have,
I can't say that for sure,
but I could tell you this.
Every one of them by by definition is
a learning experience for the organism
called humanity.
It wasn't not for the individual man.
I mean it's like you
were in the Holocaust,
you don't know.
I didn't want to participate
in a play but that,
but what did the Holocaust
teach civilization?
What did these big upheavals in
these things that are happening,
it's we're supposed to be learning.
I mean,
that's what the whole
concept of humans are.
We learn while the learning,
if you see a pattern,
you better start
responding to this pattern.
Bro.
We have learned a lot of lessons.
I said,
we've come to the end of
the way of living that way.
That's what we led to.
We were through a simple point.
You Take Darwinian theory and you
make politics out of Darwinian theory.
That's Nazi Germany.
That was Nazi Germany was science
right to the line just said,
hey,
there's a master race
and all the other ones,
the genes are no good.
Get rid of them.
And they were cleaning out the
population according to Darwinian theory.
That was science
politicized at that point.
And now it's uh,
like I had to tell you,
but I think a pharmaceutical company is
still got its roots back in that time
period.
It's a manipulation of people.
The drugs are toxic.
I love to,
I love this is a fact that it's fun.
A fun fact,
fun fact.
The third leading cause of death in
the United States as recognized by the
American Medical Association
is medicine itself.
I attra genic illnesses.
What they give a Latin term to it.
It is the third leading cause of death.
According to the medical industry.
They are the third leading cause of death.
But it was based on conservative
SMS because a paper,
when you see the medical industry,
yeah.
When you say the medical,
are you talking about pharmaceuticals?
Pharmaceutical is primarily
a medicine does miracles.
[inaudible] knocked medicine down
because medicine does miracles,
man.
Anything physical with a body,
mechanical,
they are miracle makers.
You want to transplant a heart,
you want to cut the pieces,
fix them,
go to them,
right?
You want to deal with cancer,
Alzheimer's,
diabetes,
obesity,
depression.
They have no idea what the hell they're
talking about because they know the
mechanical biology,
which gives them the opportunity
to work on the body as a vehicle,
cut out parts change parts.
But how do the parts necessarily work?
Ah,
there's some missing information because
there's the new science undermines the
existing belief system.
So that's why the failure of the system.
And it turns out that when
you do the statistics,
medicine actually becomes the leading
cause of death in the United States today.
And the pharmaceutical company is one
of the major elements behind that.
That's amazing.
That's a fact of science.
You know,
it's even more creepy as cigarettes.
So here's the secret.
Instead of taking oil of
Olay smoked cigarettes,
just go to toys r us
once a week and a sucker,
your thumb every night you'll sleep.
Well,
I don't even know what you just said.
I have no idea what you just said.
What was that?
Is that a Brian train wreck?
No,
no.
I mean,
no,
it's still entered.
He,
this is so interesting to me
because I've always thought that,
you know,
one of the secrets to life,
uh,
to,
to feeling,
looking young,
being young is to don't
ever change what you,
you're used to.
So I,
that's why I still play with toys
and that's why he was too young.
Well,
no,
no.
You just like,
I'm,
I feel like I'm a little kid still.
I'm tricking with my mind and my,
my health and everything and to
feeling like I'm a little kid.
I've always thought that a
pack of cigarettes a day.
What the fuck are you talking about?
But I go to toys r us once a week.
[inaudible] Huh?
Absolutely.
It changed that.
You're really talking
about positive things.
Your cigarette.
Of course my body thinks I'm a kid.
A lot of heat about those cigarettes.
Is it an amazing,
that's his strategy,
his strategy.
I don't want to not usually get
lung cancer from cigarettes,
but because that's the same strategy
says strychnine just not poisonous.
Exactly.
Yeah.
[inaudible] cancer that didn't think
they were going to cancel and there's
nothing cops smoking cigarettes.
I don't believe you.
Believe it enough.
How about the,
Oh yeah.
Have you seen my apartment?
I haven't seen this office.
I don't even know what that means.
Don't even know what that means.
You smoking cigarettes.
Stupid.
Ridiculous.
They're candy cigarettes.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
That's awesome.
Smoker's Pixie dust.
Right.
It's amazing is it becomes such an issue.
I look at him,
he's lighting up.
Stop talking about cigarettes.
Don't like,
oh my God.
No,
that's gross.
Why don't lighten up indoors
when nasty motherfucker,
we stink.
You have it.
We're going to.
Isn't that amazing?
We're talking about positive
thinking and beliefs and how you can
structure the world and change it for the
betterness.
Fuck.
Head lights up a cigarette
just to prove a point,
Brian.
No,
it's cause he,
that's how he is.
So he is,
I can't help it.
I just like the smoke
effect in the studio.
That's right.
That's what you like.
Just like when you,
you know,
when you used to say go
to comedy clubs like the,
like Texas,
before they banned cigarettes,
he used to always say that and states
how cool it was to go into like that.
That just adds to the
whole like sitting around,
but not in a podcast.
When you talking to a gentleman talking
about positivity and you go and do the
exact opposite of what he's selling you,
fuck,
you just became the problem,
Brian.
You are the problem.
You're the fucking,
whatever percent of it is you can't go
99% of 1% I know that they can do that
financially,
but when it comes to morons,
so much more complicated scale,
we can't just,
it's not just two groups,
man.
People are probably have
feet in both groups.
That's also an issue.
How do we fix this?
You're,
you're a smart guy.
You obviously,
instead of knowing just
knowing these things,
you must have some sort of
an idea of how it can be.
Absolutely.
How do we,
how do we implement a
positive move forward?
The first thing that's happening right
now that's really critical as occupy Wall
Street.
It's just saying,
look,
we're finished with this stuff and it
ends when enough people say it ends.
That's basically what
are going to come down.
Do you see happening
with this occupy wall?
Shoot?
What do you,
you know,
it's,
it's obviously all over the world now.
It's amazing.
You see one of those occupy
maps and you see all,
literally all over the world,
people are protesting.
But we're,
where does this end?
I think this sands,
when,
when the institutions that exist start
saying they're not able to handle the
situation anymore and then we start
looking for a new way of handling life.
I mean it was interesting when a governor,
one of the places that I had really,
I had a lot of trouble this occupy Wall
Street stuff cause I can't find anybody
to talk to that's in charge.
And uh,
it was sort of like,
yeah,
because man,
this is a new way of life.
You're not going to have
that old dental game anymore.
So all of a sudden the old guard will
not be able to communicate with a new way
of life.
And it's like the Internet.
No one runs the Internet.
There's not one person
that runs the intranet.
You know,
you could have one person that has
a show on NBC or a show on ABC.
You know,
you can have,
you could have someone
who controls a network,
but once you're on the Internet,
it's just one thing.
Just like would occupy Wall
Street is there's not one leader.
Yes.
One giant cohesive thing
all working together.
That's very fascinating.
That's why I said this,
the technology,
the Internet was the final evolutionary
stage required for civilization because
it's the nervous system
of a global civilization.
And once that was put
into place in the cell,
started communicating with each other
and once they started to do that,
then look what's unfolding
in the world around us today.
Once they,
the groups of cells from every part of
the world started looking at the same
dialogue in the same language.
And for me it's exciting.
I travel all over the place.
I give lectures.
I,
uh,
what me was a few years
back,
I was sitting in my living
room in Santa Cruz and a,
uh,
a video crew from Russia was there and
they were setting up for the video and I
was just sitting there and looking at
him and I thought if you didn't hear them
speaking,
if you just had a video without the sound,
you wouldn't know where the,
if they came from La or where
the hell they came from,
they all of a sudden start to realize
all around the world people are beginning
to,
you know,
start to act as one community of people.
And it's real exciting because that
is what the evolution is all about.
You can't have separate countries.
I say,
well look,
I'm well let,
let's burn all this crap and put it in
the air because it's going to blow over
there.
And we don't care about it that,
that those days are over.
Every nation represents cells
of people coming together.
It's like every country is
like an organ in the body.
You need all the organs to work
together to create the wholeness of it.
And that's what we're
beginning to recognize.
Know Oregon is separate
from any other Oregon.
We're all part of the same body.
So your lungs are fucking
up your whole life son.
I say,
boy,
he bikes on it.
That one doesn't let go man.
So I say your lungs are fucking up and
everything and marijuana and you're doing
it too.
No marijuana doesn't do the same
silly and he's smoking your lungs,
does it?
No it doesn't.
You're wrong.
What are you a doctor?
You fuckhead he has never read a single
thing about when you have never read a
single thing about a lung
is it has to say anyway.
It's not like it's opposite smoke.
First of all,
I don't think you're inhaling nearly
as much smoke when you smoke marijuana
cause you're only doing it like
maybe once or twice in a day.
You're sucking on those stupid
things all fucking day long.
And on top of that,
those things have 500 and
you take one bond him.
That's like a pack of cigarettes.
The fuck it is.
It's going through water.
That's not a water pipe.
Stupid as a cigarette.
All right.
Filters.
Oh my God.
Brian cigarettes are filled
with chemicals that kill you.
No one's ever died from pot ever
in the history of the world.
Do you do not get that if there's
a direct connection there,
I'm sure.
I'm sure there's people that
have died from marijuana.
No,
you might help with marijuana does
something stupid when you were high,
but that's on you.
That's not on the pots plant.
That's like,
you know,
that's like blaming a corvette
because you crashed into a tree.
It's not the car's fault
if you knew how to drive.
When you say like there's
definitely been lung cancer,
uh,
cases that are probably
attributed to marijuana.
No,
there's none.
No.
I don't know that.
They don't say it's marijuana,
smoked pot and gotten lung cancer.
It would be,
there'd be cases of it.
They would talk about it.
Look there,
there's freak instances in medicine.
There's freak instances were people's
reactions to certain things and people get
cancer from fucking all
kinds of weird shit.
That doesn't bother you or me.
But you look at the history of human use.
Where's the fucking bodies?
Dude?
You can't say that pot smoke kills people.
You can't because there's no evidence.
There's no evidence that
anybody's dying from it.
There's a lot of evidence of
people are dying from science.
Right,
but you're very strong on
this side of the case too.
I don't want you to die Canada.
No,
no.
I met a guy who was saying you're very,
even though there's no
evidence that you seem you're,
you've picked aside,
but don't you,
you're,
you're just rolling out that,
that,
that there's no one that has got lung
cancer from marijuana smoke is that guy
died.
He's a pussy.
I have one guy died.
That's what I say.
Jesus Christ.
If we kills you.
What?
Cause we'd got there first.
Dot.
Sniffing glue.
I just like,
you do it.
I don't want you to get cancer.
And I know you're stuck in this stupid
thing and it's so ridiculous because you
quit for a while and he'd talk about
how all smoke makes me sick now.
And then your cat stubs,
it's toe and you fucking
light right up again.
You know,
and you eventually you're playing a
game that's going to catch up with you.
And I think this,
this message is to anybody's out there
smoking cigarettes is the most ridiculous
fucking thing you can do.
They taste like shit.
They're terrible for you.
This whole reward mechanism is just
because you're addicted to their chemicals
and when you get that chemical,
you get this reward.
It's not even just to tobacco.
And I will say if you give a get a law
that says that ban cigarettes from the
United States,
that 90% of the smokers will cosign it.
That's right there.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I mean you don't understand what it's
like to be addicted to cigarettes.
Oh,
I imagine.
I can only imagine.
So when you talk about it to any,
I want you to be strong son.
I want you,
I get it.
Or do you think about total government
to stop smoking or Bruce Lipton?
Me that you are creating your own life,
dude.
You're creating all your own problems.
See,
he just sucks cigarettes to me.
What's happening to
you on a quantum level?
I never cigarettes to me are making
me hat was perfect and boy you happy.
We'll make the perfect foil
for this intelligent debate
we're having where Bruce
is explaining the nature of the
fucking universe and you're like,
no,
cigarettes are awesome.
Not saying
please ground so I can't stop.
I'm a smoker in front of people.
I don't care.
I don't care if it sticks.
It's like you.
It's like if someone who
really likes to Fart,
you don't care.
You just fart all over everybody
he's wearing on people,
lighting cigarettes,
all over people.
This stupidity in the air.
It's just,
and if she likes cigarettes,
man,
that's all cool and everything.
That's all cool.
And the gang,
I'm just telling my friend here,
don't be stupid,
right?
It's ridiculous.
Isn't that what you're supposed to do?
If we're supposed to reengineer the world,
I ain't supposed to call stupid shit out.
When you see it,
it's going to be great.
You're going to be the king
who's going to be the case?
No,
I don't want to see it.
I want to go back to the,
no,
I just want to be,
you know,
back in the woods.
You want to go hide in the woods.
I like that too.
Yeah.
Do you and I are on the same
you animals.
Oh fuck him in the woods.
You don't.
If you're a sensitive
person,
if you're thinking all the time and you're
sensitive to other people around you.
And I always believe that
people around you affect you.
Their energy affects you.
You don't realize how relaxing
it is when there's no one around.
When there's literally no one around.
Like you,
you sit on your porch,
you hear Chirp,
Chirp,
chirp.
You see a chipmunk walk by and you see
birds flying overhead and you see the
wind slowly moving the trees.
Fuck.
That feels awesome.
It's,
that's,
that's the east.
Yeah.
I had an experience.
Yeah,
you released from the hive briefly.
That's why I don't
understand New York City.
Well,
you're just trusting all these
people's vibes around you.
You know,
you're just going to,
to live in some giant fucking cement
box with a bunch of Weirdos and they all
think weird shit and who knows
who's toaster doesn't work right?
And lights the whole
fucking place on fire.
You're going to trust these assholes
and you're just going to be around them
every day.
Stuck in traffic and just
breathing their energy.
Right.
Uh,
I,
I W I was one of the
lucky guys in the world.
I ended up teaching the Caribbean islands.
Whoa.
I taught there for
about three years and a,
I want to talk.
You married?
Not back then.
No.
Oh yeah.
You want to talk about a line?
I offered this line and never,
it never really works.
It was like a,
it's like,
Hey,
do you want to yeah,
you got nothing to do.
I got a villa down in the Caribbean.
You want to come down there?
I had that great line,
but I really never found
anybody know that was like,
God,
what a great line in and wasting it.
That's a pretty baller line.
Well,
you know,
you know you want to come into my
place down in the crib and I go there.
Sometimes I fuck around with the
Caribbean and muck with that.
Sometimes I got a villa,
whatever,
whatever.
That's all of those things.
As well as the things you
really should have used it.
You should have forced yourself
to some sort of a bar situation.
You know?
It's why I was things,
if you would think that
if you didn't have it,
if you didn't have easy man,
if I had that boat,
I fucking use it,
but then if you did have it,
you probably wouldn't use it.
Right?
Oh,
it seems so cheesy.
The rejection could be so horrified by,
it was actually to a couple of try that.
He did try it and they rejected it,
rejected that,
and it's just like,
wow,
that didn't work.
I'm really bad.
When you see something
really cheesy like that,
you take a chance that it goes,
you know the girls basically
in materialistic slut.
Then final checks don't like that.
Yeah.
That's really,
you're taking a big bold chance.
It's like when Bill Clinton used to just
pull his dick out in front of girls.
You know,
like,
man,
I guess that works sometimes.
He was holy shit,
what a gamble.
He represented the
testosterone or the country,
so he was,
you know,
that's what he was.
Must have worked so many times.
There's no way it didn't
work because all these,
like the state trooper
woman that Jennifer Flowers,
women,
these women that would claim we would
just whip his dick out and it was not just
one,
you know,
it was like,
it had obviously,
what's his Goto?
Well,
it was an unconscious behavior.
He didn't see himself doing it,
but I mean,
I can't believe he did it with like women
and like professional environments and
stuff.
I mean,
he wasn't like a loan
at his house to have it.
A couple of drinks and
he just whips it out now.
He would whip it out when the
first person left the room,
you know,
they'd be like,
three people in the room.
I'll be right back and
we'll go to the bathroom.
And then one person
would go to the bathroom,
he'd whip his dick out.
I mean he was fucking crazy.
It was king.
He was king.
Yeah.
But is it natural to have
that kind of behavior?
Like is that,
isn't that what drives a lot of those
guys to get to that position in the first
place?
Absolutely.
Because you're in that competition
out there in the field.
And how do you know how you
succeed in the competition?
How many toys do you own and what's
your position in the hierarchy?
And so w when you driven
yourself to that level there,
there was a reason why you
want it to be up there.
Not to just because there's something to
do for the week or something like that.
There was a mission statement.
So they that was playing the
game fallout going for that.
This is why the Atlanta people
really identify with Ron Paul.
And one of the reasons why
they identify with Ron Paul.
He,
no,
he doesn't want to fuck anybody.
Yeah,
he's like an old dude.
It's not like he's not like I'm
some crazy pussy prowl and you know,
once he gets an office he'll
be playing golf every day,
you know?
No,
he's done with everything and any thought
of anything masculine are dominating
and you know,
he's done with all that and absolutely.
And it would be great to,
I could,
I could just see it happening
because of the Internet community.
A third party could arise
within just several weeks.
Do you think voting is real voting?
I don't think it's not great.
I think it's set up.
Yeah.
Especially with computer voting machines.
Did you watch that
documentary hacking democracy?
I've seen that and I know some of these
people in the industry and it's sort of
like,
yeah that's,
that's just a given.
But what's a gift?
What's insane is that that wasn't followed
up on and chase down and beaten down
in front of the press.
Like,
like that girl killed her
baby with the fuck's her name,
Casey Anthony,
that that got beaten down,
you know,
that got beaten down to the press.
Why wasn't this?
Because obviously anything that was
important doesn't play in the press.
The press is owned by the
people that own the opinion.
They'll play what they want.
I mean,
when,
when to haven't they
done that disgust you,
that's why the Internet is so,
that's why they lost control all of a
sudden want to fuck up the Internet is
Huh?
It's pirate radio for the whole world.
Exactly.
You know what a disaster.
Yeah.
People think for themselves and the fun
stuff is that Rodney came to people,
I don't remember,
but Rodney King was the beginning of uh,
everybody getting caught on camera,
you know,
and I love it.
And like,
yeah,
you're right.
You know,
once that opened up,
once I opened up all
of a sudden it's like,
oh,
you mean you could expose the secrets?
And everybody had cameras
like the UC Davis thing.
That was a great,
that's a great demonstration how they,
they peaceably just push the
guys right out of the thing.
But it was neat,
was like 50% of the audience at their
hands up with cameras and everybody was
shooting.
His whole thing is sort
of like in this world.
I don't think that guy thought
that that was going to happen.
No,
I don't think he was going to get,
I think he never thought he
would get contacted about it.
That's just police all thought that was
amazing to me that someone could think
that it would be the right thing to
do to take some fucking kid who was a
college student.
Okay.
And all they're doing is sitting there
protesting and you're going to spray some
fifth whatever they are,
1920 year old kid in the face with
pepper spray and you're a cop,
whatever piece a shit that and that,
that reaction is completely
natural and important.
Right,
because that is verification that
there's a new process in place.
Absolutely.
And that's what I was so proud about
those people because they'd gotten into a
situation where it could
have gotten into violence.
And what they did is they,
they just held the violence
back and just,
you know,
there's just shame on you.
And they shamed them,
like push them back back until they were
off the campus and they got off and it
was like,
oh wow.
Nonviolence,
because what people have to understand
is that it's the violence that's being
planted.
I think most of it I would say a is
planted is to throw people against this
occupy Wall Street movement.
When and,
and when they did a piece of leaves,
like,
wow,
what are you gonna how are you
going to complain about that?
Were,
you know,
it was like,
that was a great demonstration of,
uh,
of how to handle this situation
because the moment violence comes in,
then the,
those,
they're almost like Nazi
storm troopers out there,
especially with all of that,
uh,
homeland security,
you know,
all that crap.
All their new guns and all that,
that technology for crowd control,
they're freaky people out there.
And it's like,
and they love the job.
They love to go out there
and pound on those kids.
That's what they,
they train for.
So,
so ridiculous.
It's very fascinating though.
It's very fascinating the,
the tone that the movement has taken,
the fact that it's really
been amazingly nonviolent,
considering the amount of resistance,
that's what it needs.
Because otherwise,
if it's,
if you're going to play the game of force,
you're already out.
You're not going to win the game.
What do you think is going to happen?
Or do you,
do you sit down and prognosticate?
Do you see a direction
that this is going to
go do it there?
There's two choices here around the
choices are we're going to survive this
evolutionary thing or we're
not going to survive it.
So,
uh,
we continued doing what we're doing.
We already know.
Science already said,
it's already on the calendar manager.
You're,
you're going out.
And the question is,
can we mobilize and make the change?
And I really think we can because it's,
um,
especially the younger
generation and the older,
older generation,
the ones in the middle lobe.
But I'm a little concerned about,
but there are a lot of old
hippies out there that,
that uh,
really are in total alignment with
the occupy Wall Street movement.
That's who they are.
They were there back then
when it all happened and so,
uh,
I think there's this great
opportunity for this evolution.
It's going to be fabulous,
but you have to recognize like
anything when a child is born is there,
there's blood,
there's,
there's a pain and blood when it happens
and birthing this new civilization.
We're going to go through this
little bit of this chaos here,
which is going to be
painful for a lot of people,
but it's like we got to see pass
where we are and look to where we,
isn't it amazing that no one would have
ever guessed 20 years ago that we'd be
talking about tests that we'd be talking
about society eroding to the point
where it really becomes
irrelevant or not irrelevant,
but just it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it's not respected.
Now,
you know,
the,
the setup is we've accepted it
because it just is what it is.
No one is happy with it.
Everybody recognizes it's full of flaws.
But it's almost like there's this attitude
that like this is as good as we can
as humans.
Oh
No.
I mean today there's complicated society
with the stock market and the exchange
rates and so,
you know,
Saudi Arabian Oil,
this is as good as we can get,
but it's not obvious.
Not because it's not perfect to keep
those people that have the haves to keep
what they have and to keep
all the other people in,
in that place.
But instead of evolving,
it's in fact evolving.
Absolutely.
But that's what's going
to cost to come to a head,
come to a crisis point where something's
going to have to happen right here.
I have to realize that the people that
are in power are not looking out for
their interest.
It's an obvious,
it's obvious this do this new thing
that was passed in the Senate about,
uh,
the,
the United States being a battlefield.
Oh Man.
Did you,
you see this,
that they're allowed to mobilize
troops now on American soil.
Apparently Obama said
he's going to veto it,
but what the fuck ever,
man,
the fact that it got that
far in the first place,
that's horrific.
It's just this manipulation by
very small number of people.
Like,
you know,
Alyssa,
we're going to extend unemployment,
but you have to sign for the pipeline.
And what point in time does that become
criminal for like the Senate and what
point in time did we not say,
hey,
you fucking crux.
Get outta here.
Well,
I'm waiting.
I'm totally waiting for this.
And it's really upsetting.
And that's why I actually started looking,
I even looked for a place in New Zealand
now it's going to be so hard to get rid
of lobbyists.
It's going to be so hard,
that kind of shit.
It's going to be so hard
to get all that stuff out.
Look at the Internet,
as I said,
could overnight changed the entire
political spectrum overnight.
They'd never counted on that.
And if you do something,
voting is real.
If voting is real,
but then the idea is you really
start to swamp the market,
it's very hard to say that.
Uh,
you know,
that's what these other countries,
no,
it's like,
well obviously this didn't
conform to the people.
Isn't it funny that we are becoming
a fucking banana dictatorship?
We are.
We have become everything we fought for
for other countries and and freed other
countries.
We've imposed with a Patriot Act.
We have taken her away personal liberty
and this whole country is to my opinion,
would that person would that Patriot Act
and operation is as bankrupt as any of
the countries.
Like Chile was a under under
their leadership and their
dictators were whatever
the government says they
can create wherever the hell
they want to take you Joe
off the street and not tell anybody
for 90 days that you are even gone.
They've just done incredible
like in America it's incredible.
Like whoever's sign that you are traders.
Absolutely guys are traders,
just straight traders.
They should be fucking
ashamed of themselves.
To call yourself a representative
of the people and the past,
something like that.
What do,
what do,
what do you think?
What if,
what if everything at the
top is completely fucked up
and the right thing to do
is to march in the street and to
block traffic and to stop this fucking
tyrannical situation.
It's that necessarily.
If that is the case,
then we're there.
Anybody you poses that is treasonous.
Yeah,
look,
they,
they already have the interment camps to
hold several million people and there,
because this was not a new thing.
A matter of fact,
there was a guy at Stanford University
at this think tank called the Hoover
think tank.
Uh,
in 1980,
the government asked him to write a
report on a scenario if there's a big
financial
collapse,
1980.
They asked him to write this.
He said,
well,
you know,
the,
these were game players.
How would you play this thing out?
And the thing was,
it was real interesting.
He said,
uh,
in this process of what they
were talking about in the future,
uh,
the guy who wrote it up said,
one of the things that was interesting,
he said,
people in this future period,
you're going to become more conscious
and this is going to change the
relationship of what's going on.
But he also came to the conclusion,
he said,
inevitably we're still going to come to
a chaos period where there's going to
have to be controlled,
maintain.
And I remember we put in
parentheses and he said,
and I hope not for long,
but what he was saying is if it comes
to a crunch issue like this for the
government to maintain control,
they'll have to put a lot of people away
and in German camps disease to keep it
from,
from burning up.
And I mean,
look,
it's not very far now.
I mean the,
the,
the essentially storm
troopers and Oakland and uh,
and all these other cities
coming in there with,
I mean,
it's like,
it's out of some other country's history
book and we're looking at a life.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's terrifying.
It's weird how quickly it happened to,
you know,
you remember a right after nine
11 when everybody was like,
oh Rah Rah.
I remember it was just,
you know,
week or so after the tragedy.
I was driving down the street and
every other car had an American flag.
Yeah,
no,
it's amazing.
Everybody was all we blew it.
Yeah.
Cause there was an evolutionary moment.
It was right on the edge
because all around the world,
all the countries,
that one started to say let's unite
together and stamp out this stuff.
And then it was,
you know,
a cowboy.
George said,
no,
I'll do it myself.
You know,
and sort of,
I think Dick Cheney said,
let's just go ahead and take the same
dick.
Cheney just went in and stole everything.
There's Darth Vader,
real life man.
So yeah,
it's fucking hard.
Doesn't even have a pulse.
No,
he doesn't have a policy.
He's got some crazy pacemaker
in him to keep him alive.
Like what doctor thinks?
It's a good idea to keep that do it alive.
Oh my God.
And Hollywood animatronics.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
What do you want them to be
around to influence John Horn?
Make crazy decisions.
He's had a long time and he's,
he's done good.
The fact that he managed to
get this far and still live,
considering how many people,
he's probably responsible for themselves.
You know,
that,
that whole secret government
stuff with Howard.
Damn.
I remember when he was
always in the bunker to,
he would always hide in the bunker.
That was like the craziest shit ever.
George Bush be out playing
golf mile underground,
you know,
cause they were,
they didn't want to Dick Cheney to die,
you know,
was,
it's a male,
he's the guy pulling
the marionette strings.
But isn't that like the first time ever
that we can recall that there was a
real,
like the vice president really was
sort of in control of the whole thing,
you know,
I mean,
I don't remember that happening during
the Carter administration or ranking
administration or,
well,
Reagan himself wasn't
in charge of anything.
He was,
he was a figure,
but I remember he was,
he was a,
an an ad spokesman on television,
early days of television for things like
General Electric and big corporations.
Yeah.
Who was that guy that would
distinguish and they just
bought him from the television set and
put them in front of the world and,
and gave him the lines to read.
He was an actor.
He did all the lines.
It's amazing though,
how many people respected him.
It's like people that argue that Hulk
Hogan really did fight all those guys like
this.
People,
you know,
if you ever seen those
dudes on the Internet,
like there's one,
there's a very famous clip
of one guy and he's in a,
he's in a high school auditorium or
something and he's talking to these
wrestlers and he's crying
and he's literally crying.
He's like,
I just want to thank you.
Oh,
what you do?
If you ever seen that clip,
right?
The coach talking to the players.
This is real to me.
It's real to me.
No,
he's a find that dude.
He's a,
he's a pro wrestling fan.
It's fucking hilarious.
So what should I search for?
It's real to me.
It's still real to me.
But you gotta see this guy,
this,
this guy,
man.
You get to learn a lot,
but it really is along the same lines,
you know people that just,
they don't want to hear it.
That's most of the population
as far as I can tell.
They can see it in front
of their faces and don't,
don't even say anything.
A lot of people are too busy too.
That's another,
it's very hard to even concentrate on
anything other than watching TV and eating
after you work all day.
It's fucking hard,
man.
And if you go to the gym too,
oh Jesus.
What do you have time for?
You know,
you take a spinning class or you know,
you do,
you know,
whatever to some place of racquetball
or something and you know,
after that's over,
man,
how much time do you
have to fix the world?
You've got to go to bed,
do it all over again.
Stupid.
Put down a sign,
you know,
they'll get a job and be over with
everybody's gonna fall asleep.
All right.
Did you find him?
There he is.
Brian.
That was it.
Yes.
Hold on one sec.
Just isn't that,
is that a problem that people are
working all the time and they're tired?
It's very difficult to get a fucking
movement going with a bunch of people were
tired from work.
All right,
here we go.
Yeah,
but I think guys,
how many people are not working
anymore so she got this poor guy.
I want to thank each and every one he out.
Thank you all guys.
You're awesome.
Thank you so much,
Mr. Fuck,
per se,
of what needed to be.
Isn't that amazing?
That's how far the mind could wander.
How do we bring that guy back?
How do we get turned that guy
into the coolest guy in the world?
Oh,
what?
The mushrooms that would help it.
That was going to hold them down.
Now I'm thinking I got hold him down.
Of course faith is brought out a funnel.
It's like you're trying to make frog raw.
I like those things they do at ducks.
They force feed them to
make their living room,
which by the way is delicious.
You ever had that fog was going to be
illegal in California at the end of this
month,
people have decided they're going to
outlaw this fog while we've got Susan is
wrong,
what they're doing to these ducts that
they're eventually going to fucking kill
and eat anyway.
But meanwhile,
cigarettes,
illegal whacking fucking
Douche bag government.
We have Joe,
did you see the architect
that just released?
Dude for real team people.
Okay.
Did you see that,
that architect that just released
those in the new building,
uh,
drawings that they're going to make a
building that looks just like nine 11
here's,
here's a picture of it
wrong on the screen,
right behind you.
Juiciness.
I,
it's,
it's actually,
at first you look at it and you're like,
oh,
that's just creepy looking.
But then the more you look into it,
it's actually really cool.
Like it was like,
oh,
what was I kind of the clouds.
The idea is that it sticks above
the clouds because it's so high.
But it also looks like a fucking planes
like,
exactly.
Yeah.
But what kind of fucking
cloud is like a pixelated car?
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting though.
It's probably a dope building.
Let them build it.
Who gives a shit?
What are they,
you know,
are,
we are so sensitive to explosions
and buildings and you know,
is it like Muhammad and now you can't
draw the nine 11 hours will go after you.
You Fuck,
oh no.
Strange Place America.
Yeah.
The whole world,
right?
Yeah.
But,
uh,
we're,
we're great leaders.
Well,
we're better than the Middle East man.
Check out what the fuck they're doing.
Blocks of people when they're
dancing and all that bullshit.
We are less oppressive than them.
Isn't that funny?
That's like a badge of honor.
You know,
we fucked you less hard.
Well,
I've tried all we kiss you chartered yet.
You know,
cause that's the one different to all
the other countries that they get in the
revolution.
They throw rocks and
bottles at each other.
We've got AK 47 is automatic weapons.
So,
uh,
a revolution here,
it's going to have a whole
different name and we're not,
we're also not under a religious
fundamentalists rule completely.
Not completely,
but in process and process,
you think you feel like it's
going in that direction.
All the Republicans,
that's their,
that's their whole model just because
that's the best way to rape in the retards
or rope in the retards,
you know,
gets a good pattern that they
can adapt and think that way.
But if you believe like Rick Perry is
looking out for God and you know God would
want that fucking dope
being the president,
that guy,
we never have.
You seen a guy in a debate that forgot
like a primary part of being a fucking
politician.
Why?
What do you stand for?
Stupid.
Do you have your shit and measure,
memorize.
You have it written down anywhere.
He didn't even have
notes in front of them.
You know,
whether he's talking about the
three branches of government,
who's going to get rid
of and he'd be blanked.
It's amazing.
And yet the first move he did after that
was to put out a thing about being a
Christian and a about the gays don't
want you to celebrate the whole world's
falling apart and all this stuff
and they want to see on her face.
You guys,
there's big issues here
and they don't want,
they don't deal with any big as well.
They're mining for low hanging fruit
and that's the best way to mine.
That's an unfortunate situation.
When I think I remember back
at some advertisements like,
oh George Bush would be the
kind of president he liked
to go have a beer with at
the bar,
and I'm thinking,
not really.
I wouldn't have a beer with them just
to see how fucking guilty he feels.
Oh,
you know,
just to see what it's like.
I would definitely have
a beer with that guy.
I think he's a spokesperson and the the,
the,
the thing that I always point to is the,
the time when that dude
was throwing shoes at him.
Yeah,
no,
that,
he talked to me,
he's like smiling.
He had this look on his face.
That to me was like,
this is the first fund
this fucking guy has had,
you know,
in years.
Finally he's having a good time.
Well Tony Hsieh,
just fucking work here.
I am responsible.
How much is big Mac is,
you know,
it's basically like he was behind the
counter at Mcdonald's and someone through
their shoes at him.
He probably hated that day.
He probably had the worst night.
No,
I don't think that all,
I think he's happy for a moment.
Did,
he's like secret service of following
them every day with bulletproof fast and
fucking guns and tanks and cars.
You can't blow up.
He's having a good time.
Once I was selling shoes out
of mass torts moment for him.
Yeah.
It was like something was
actually happening in his
life that they didn't plan
out in advance and pull off to a t
where the whole world thought they were
battling good guys starting fucking wars
over weapons that don't even exist and
even those,
it's been proven those
weapons don't exist.
Oh,
we're just going to stay for
another seven or eight years.
Look,
we got rid of a bad guy.
You know,
like this whole thing that's
going on in Afghanistan.
I mean it's,
it's amazing that people,
anybody supports it.
Who is a lot of people,
man.
And a lot of politicians support it.
Obviously that's why we're the
best government money can buy,
but it isn't.
It's amazing that anybody could,
I mean,
if you needed the best example ever of,
of how the government and the military
are not looking out for your best
interest and Afghanistan is it
to think that we didn't learn,
not only do we not learn
anything from Vietnam,
we learned less.
This is a dumb or war.
This is way dumber.
Right?
It's way dumb,
right?
Know probably last longer.
The money was good though.
You have to make the money was great.
It's an amazing way to make some money.
It's amazing.
That was the whole motivation.
It's just push the money around for that.
Yeah,
I was looking at there,
they had something in the
news the other day about the,
the amount of heroin that's been produced.
It's something like 61% more in
2011 then in 2010 it's incredible.
And it's really a response
to the price increasing,
so they're just making an insane,
someone isn't making insane amounts of
money from that insane amounts of money.
I invest in heroin.
Do you?
We're going to have that
Michael Ruper dot guy on Dj.
Did you get that message?
The collapse guy sits there and just says,
we're fucked.
We're fucked.
Or that kind of documentary.
Yeah,
he's going to do it.
Yeah.
Oh,
wow.
We're setting that up.
You hear about the alarming toxins found
in the baby food like they're finding
can baby food.
They're finding in Japan,
the monsters in Japan,
they're,
they're finding from the,
that whole shit.
There's fallout there,
stuffing the baby food.
Of course it is.
It's probably in everything.
It's probably in the ground.
I mean,
that's why when Shane was here and he
was telling us the Tokyo was two hours
away and I was like,
I'm going to go two hours away from that,
even going for a couple of days.
That's terrifying for me.
Those poor people have to live there
and that that stuff is going to get into
their water and stuff's going to get in
their food and how many people are going
to be irradiated before they
actually do something about it?
You know,
Dana White's going to come
back with a full head of hair,
healthier.
Your worst
was no way do I think it actually
makes your hair fall out silly,
but these are the lesson
back with no eyebrows.
These are the lessons then
whether we learn them or not,
that's this period.
There's no way to fix that right there.
That Fukushima,
how do you say the name Fukushima
Focus Shayma you can't fix that,
right?
I mean that's gone.
That's going fuck.
And they can't even contain the,
the,
the core,
right?
Isn't it like melted terms of container?
It'll be contained to planet earth.
It probably won't go past planet earth,
but it will stay on plan
it or isn't it amazing?
It's amazing that people still will
say that we should have nuclear energy.
It was like,
what if one of these things
goes wrong every 20 years?
Do you understand that in
the course of human history,
the whole planet,
it's fucked.
It's like takes over a hundred thousand
years for people to be able to go
anywhere near that without dying.
Right.
We have a short term memory problem,
but I mean that's how
ridiculous calculation.
Yeah.
And yet the people,
as long as it's in the
front of the newspaper,
then it's there.
And the moment it's not
in front of the newspaper,
it's gone.
He'd be like,
Vino what?
The nuclear power has an amazing record.
No,
it doesn't.
I can tell you three times that I know
and I'm not even barely paying attention.
Three Mile Island was that chemicals?
No,
no.
Through my [inaudible] as well.
Three Mile Island,
Chernobyl,
and Fukushima.
Kashima that's three.
And each one got bigger than the last one.
That's ridiculous.
If you know three fuckups,
you know three fuck ups in your life,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
But we have here in California,
our nuclear plants on
the fault line as well.
What the fuck is wrong with us?
Are we crazy?
Are we doing this on purpose?
I don't really like
playing chicken down dumb.
We down dumbed ourselves so that we're,
we're more easily control.
We didn't do it.
It's just like we're playing chicken w
w it seems like we're a guy or is your
wife goes to the gym and you call a
prostitute into your house and it's like
you're,
it's a race against time.
She back in and get the fuck out of here.
It's like you almost
wanting to get caught.
You're a crazy person.
You know when you're building a
fucking power plant on a fault line,
you know,
if I was your psychologist,
I'd be like,
Oh man,
what the fuck are you doing man?
Hey man,
the land was cheap.
You couldn't put that over here.
Couldn't put that over
here where it never moved.
It seems ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's a good spot.
It seems to just as ridiculous
that we all live here though.
Fuck [inaudible] man.
That was my number one feelings for like
why does everybody have to live in this
one spot is so stupid.
And that's what I felt like when you
live in a place that only has a few
thousand people and it's like woo,
you get to breathe,
you can fucking relax.
Yeah.
Why do we do this?
Why do we group up like those?
Cause we get things done easier this way.
No,
it's just a nature of a cell.
Started to do that before we did that
sells lived in community and then they
called we the unhealthy cells cause we
separate from the pack and want to hide
in the woods.
Well the whole idea is there's
definitely some a bad growth in the,
in the colony.
It's got cancer itself.
System's got cancer itself.
So when you look at the future and you
see with all the information that you
have,
which is far more than most,
how do you see this ending?
I think this the
the greatest possible,
most wonderful ending in the world.
Let me just give example.
For some people we talked about the
conscious mind and that we're being
controlled by the subconscious mind and
that the conscious mind is a creative
mind with your wishes and desires.
Well,
here's an interesting fact.
Go back to a time sometime you,
you fell head over heels
in love with somebody.
I call it the honeymoon period.
And then I say in that honeymoon period
where you healthy and almost everybody
wanted,
I'm going to ask a big audience,
almost everybody goes like,
exuberantly healthy.
When I was in that pair and I said,
did you have vintage?
He's like,
yeah,
we had so much energy.
We made love for days,
didn't even stop for food,
man.
And I say,
it was life so beautiful that you couldn't
wait for the next day to have more of
that.
And everybody goes,
yeah,
yeah.
And I go,
just think about it.
Is that tantamount to having
heaven on earth as it is that,
would that be something like that?
And everybody goes,
Oh yeah.
And then I go,
that was not an accident.
That was a personal creation.
And that the honeymoon was
the one time in our lives.
And this is the interesting part because
neuroscience says the one time where
you operate strictly from the conscious
mind and don't revert to that default
program in the subconscious mind where
you're operating from your wishes and
desires is the time you're making love.
When you're making love,
the conscious mind stays
in the present moment.
Well,
why is that relevant?
It's the conscious mind.
It has all your wishes and desires.
So if that mine stays in the front,
guess what?
Then you created a life
that was heaven on earth,
but the moment life starts to get too
busy and your mind starts to wander and
think,
then you start,
you go,
you resort back to the
unconscious programs.
While you didn't see you did that,
but your partner does
and your partner goes,
what?
They,
how can I behaviors that?
Where'd that come from?
And that's when this whole
honeymoon starts to come to an end.
Because when you just said whatever
you did from your subconscious program,
which may have been your father or your
mother and you didn't hear yourself say
it,
your partner heard yourself say,
you didn't even hear yourself saying that.
So that's where all of a
sudden a honeymoon starts off,
starts to collapse is like,
what do you,
you know,
what are you talking about?
I've always been this way,
or whatever you want to say.
It's like you start losing a dialogue
because you're now talking from your
subconscious programs and,
but the whole point was what?
When we did operate from the conscious
moment when we did stay in that period,
we created heaven on
earth both health wise and
yeah,
but then she got fat bitch at me about
shit and I'm tired of the fucking texting
my friends,
you've got a problem with me,
talked to me.
Isn't that what happens?
They get tired of their own bullshit.
Conscious mind started.
Normally people too,
you know traveling,
it's a utopian concept because we were
talking about is this massive upbeat
apprise of Serotonin too,
right?
Absolutely.
Dopamine,
Serotonin and easily happens
when you first meet someone.
You want to fuck them
cause you're discussing.
You know,
because the question is,
the question is why did it disappear?
No disappeared.
Because you,
when you met that person,
both of you were operating from
your creative wishes and desires.
When did it fall apart?
Is when the subconscious
mind started or to
take over more of the operation because
life started to occupy your conscious
mind.
Now traveling.
Yeah,
that's when it ended.
So you hit this perfect moment
and then life got in the way.
Yeah,
and the guest one.
But if you reprogram the subconscious
mind to have the same beliefs in wishes
and desires at your conscious mind has
so that both minds have the same vision
and destiny.
Then there's a honeymoon
the rest of your life.
It doesn't end then because you
put in your wishes and desires.
So even when you're not paying attention,
that's when your subconscious plane is
still going to play the same wishes and
desires that you want in your life anyway.
But right now it plays the programs that
you got from other people when you're
not paying attention.
That's why you lose
control over your life set.
I've always said that very few
people have their own opinions,
that they simply have a conglomeration
of other people's opinions.
It's sort of adopt it as their own,
but they really haven't like audited.
Every single one of them downloaded a
lot of them and try to figure out why is
that in there.
Yeah,
and the problem,
once it's downloaded,
then you become a slave to the program.
Even if you have no desire
to be in the program,
it not your choice.
Now it's unconscious.
It'll take you there whether you're paying
attention or not and don't you think
that same sort of thing has happened to
pretty much everyone who's in a position
of power,
so they are in a certain sense
of victim of the same system.
They've been told Randall of they were
program somewhere along the line to get
to that power so that they were
being driven by the program.
It's amazing when you really
think about it that you know what?
One of the things I think is really
terrifying to people is that you're
describing this and
people are realizing this,
I'm sure right now,
but they're also realizing that this is
not a conventional idea that's really
sort of pushed in the media.
This is not something the president
United States addresses the nation about.
And this is not necessarily
something that's,
there's no money,
there's no money for the
corporations in this process.
And when,
when the information is expressed and
you know and people know it to be true,
sort of recognize it and think,
oh my God,
does this mean that there was no one who
has set this whole gigantic thing up,
this human civilization?
No one did it consciously,
no one planned it out.
They might have made the infrastructure
and planned out where the water was
going to go this way anyway,
it was going to go this way,
planned out electricity in a pattern.
We're playing a pattern
and here's the pattern.
A civilization is a living organism and
animal and by its definition is going to
involve in the same characteristic
way than animals evolved.
So there was a part we
went from let's say a fish,
amphibians,
reptiles,
birds and mammals.
The fish phase was when
human civilization,
earliest phase mariculture culture.
They lived at the sea.
They had to live with the water.
They,
they couldn't live without water.
They were stuck to wherever the water was.
Agriculture was the amphibian phase stage.
Why they took the water with them on a
land so they could go deep into the land,
penetrating land,
get the water,
grow all the stuff and live
because you needed the water.
Okay.
The reptiles stage,
um,
reptiles are the only animals
that were first designed for land.
They were almost like machines.
They're,
they're,
they're almost mechanical.
Like when you see a lizard,
like it's almost digital.
The way it moves.
The reptiles were the equivalent
of the industrial age.
That's when we became reptilian.
And it's interesting cause we're still
in that age and guess what we're fueling
this civilization with,
with what they call the,
the blood of the dinosaur.
We're,
we're fueling it with oil,
which is the character of that,
that reptilian phase.
And so we're living a reptilian
phase of civilization.
The lizards were like mom and pop shops,
but they grew into dinosaurs,
which are corporations and
the corporations evolve.
And then here comes the cool part.
The bird phase of human civilization
started in 1903 when Wilbur and Orville
Wright started the fly.
It changed the whole world because now
you can fly around in a few hours to
change.
The world was so massive.
At one point,
nobody could imagine it.
Now we can fly around it and put
a satellite around it and I say,
so the birds evolved
from 1903 but guess what?
They reached their fullest evolution.
In 1969 1969 the Burj landed on the moon
and they took a picture of the earth
and those hippies back then saw this
picture and created Earth Day within two,
within a month or two of
of the picture coming back,
number one.
Number two,
they said,
Oh man,
look at that.
We got to take care of that.
That's all we have.
Got to take care of the water,
the air,
take care of the kids and all that.
Taking care is to
character called nurturing.
Nurturing is the character of mammals.
So in 1969 the mammalian phase of human
civilization was seeded with the hippies
looking and say,
oh my God,
take care of each other,
take care of the planet.
We generation is what it was all about.
But then go back in history and
recognize when the mammals first evolved.
The dinosaurs were still here too.
And the dinosaurs were,
you know,
the big,
big killer things in a mammals
where the little meek furry guys,
right.
And the fact is they talk about
the meek taking over the earth.
Well we're in that transition.
The dinosaur is falling,
the oil is running out.
The the,
you know,
the power that's been feeding this whole
reptilian phase of corporate dinosaurs.
Nick is actually the individuals all
banded together against the United
cooperation or absolutely.
And see the young people that are taking
care of each other and recognize why
this whole non,
this really,
this nonviolence movement
is almost prophetic.
Absolutely will inherit the earth.
That's what it's all about.
And,
and someone back then when who wrote
the Bible or wrote any of the religious
texts that they,
if they go through this already now,
I don't know.
You know,
there's a,
there's interesting
things about that is a,
I believe a lot of that,
um,
uh,
we translate the Bible,
whatever people think today an issue is
maybe they were writing about real shit
back then.
That really happened.
Something happened here on this planet
or an upheaval occurred in that biblical
time period globally and
things shifted on the planet.
It's possible that this
has happened before.
That we just fucked the whole thing.
Yes.
Almost start from scratch.
Oh Wow.
It seems like it's manageable.
Memoria Atlantis and,
and that was a natural disasters,
right?
That's what they,
what we believe.
But we don't know about the law,
the law,
the Maureen was more of
the natural disaster.
What about the Atlantis when it's still
don't know what actually happened?
It was a tsunami.
They found it in Spain member.
Well,
they're finding pieces all over cause
there we're finding now every that the
war,
that the water level is much higher
than it used to be a long time ago.
And so,
and everything just like
now we live on the edges.
So if the water level raises than anything
on the edges doesn't exist anymore.
So we lost it all at some point.
But there's a time that this
has happened before the,
the Mayans,
the INCAS,
I mean they created buildings that
were completely earth proof designed
earthquake proof.
And they,
they are,
they already knew that this was,
this world was just going to shake
and do all this kind of stuff.
Something was hot and they
make earth proof earthquake.
If you look at these giant giant blocks,
I mean they're so big,
by human size,
I mean they're massive stones.
They're cut with very intricate angles.
And the point about it is they're
designed that if the wall shakes,
the stones loosen up,
but then they'll all settle back down
into the original resting position.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So they designed this knowing full
well that these massive earthquakes,
we're gonna move these boulders,
size building blocks a and yet
they're designed so they're,
their angles are cut so that they loosen
up in an earthquake and then fall back
into everything.
Slides back into the,
the right,
you know,
the right structure was before.
That's amazing.
It's amazing that they somehow
or another figure that out.
I was interested because they built a,
when the Christians came in
into the Spanish and they,
they,
they took over the Sun Temple,
which is this big Peruvian temple,
uh,
in Cusco.
Uh,
then the church that it,
uh,
and like dogs pee one
on top of the other one.
They built their church on top of the,
the foundation,
which was the Peruvian temple
they built a church on.
Wow.
And it's interesting.
Three earthquakes have demolished the
church each time and in three earthquakes,
not one thing happened to
the foundational building,
which was the Peruvian temple.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's totally a,
they knew all this stuff.
There was great technology.
There was a lot of stuff
happening in those,
there's something that,
there are civilizations that
we don't talk about in history.
Books are history,
book talks about,
Oh,
the Middle East,
uh,
Babylon and all that kind of stuff.
It was a source and it's like there were
civilizations that were here and died
out that were much more
advanced before that.
I believe that.
Yeah.
Oh,
they got enough archaeology.
I'm just showing that now.
There's,
there's definitely some
evidence that points to that.
A new everything.
Everything's being revised.
That's the greatest thing about that.
Every part of our
knowledge is being revised.
And that's another thing that
people are fighting against.
Um,
you know,
when you were talking about people who
are academics who have been teaching a
certain thing,
most of their lives,
you know,
that happened with a lot of this,
uh,
the train,
the people that are trying
to predate the Sphinx.
So you'll wear he,
oh yeah.
To me.
That's a perfect example
because these people,
these Egyptologists like,
you know,
where's
this evidence of this culture and there,
you know,
and like,
man,
how much evidence you really think there
would be if you're really talking about
34,000 years ago or something like that
and like how much evidence is there
going to be?
What's really going to be anything
other than blocks of stone?
I mean,
when we let go of a city,
how long did it take before their
things back into sand again?
It doesn't take long.
No,
not at all at all.
I mean,
how long would a car last
and left a car outside?
It will last.
Even I'm old enough to have a few cars
I've left in the woods that are probably
not there anymore.
Yeah,
right.
You remember when kids used to do that?
I remember when dudes used to have cars
that would just sit on blocks and you'd
see fucking trees growing in their car.
We had a,
a mountain near where we lived
and we'd go by these junkers,
you know,
cars that were burning oil and people
didn't want really pay 10 15 bucks,
drive him up to the top of this hill.
And then we,
we use them like a dirt track and it just,
you know,
cut through the weeds and all kinds of
stuff like that and just random into the
ground until they finally,
so it was like 10 or 15 bucks for the
investment and then spend a day or two
plane,
you know,
uh,
bumper
cars stuff up
before we were aware that
we could hurt ourselves.
When you're young and silly.
I friend of mine had a van and
he parked it in his garage.
He never fucking used it.
Just,
it was all broken down a junkie.
And one day we went into it and there
was a plant growing out of his floor mat
and almost like I was
looking at it as like,
dude,
nature's gonna eat this.
Nature's going to slowly figure
out a way to eat your truck.
It just,
we're seeing like day 70 something
that's going to take a million days,
but it'll eat this fucking thing
that's going to be nothing left to say.
What would there'd be leftover things.
It's like most of our stones stuff
will be gone in a short time.
Yeah,
just stone.
That's about it.
Which is really terrifying to me because
now we're moving into this digital era
and everything is getting put down
on ones and Zeros data that you have,
and we're also going to hit an air of
sunspot activity that's going to be
courageous,
which means all that memory going to go,
oh,
that's so ridiculous.
Could you imagine if that happened and
it was just some super big gamma burst at
fucking erased.
Everyone's hard drive.
Everyone all over the world.
Not,
not,
you know,
I didn't know it was a question anymore.
We go right back to
fucking from Wikipedia.
We have to go find some
books in a library and Shit.
Wander the desert.
40 years in darkness.
That's a God damn.
If that happens,
I don't know what I want to do.
I really don't know.
I don't know if I want
to get swept up in the,
in the,
in the fucking hurricanes that kill
people or if I want to try to help my DVD
player,
my,
uh,
and my television keep working,
cause I'll,
I'll just watch movies
as a sunset continues
really just hanging out on a hilltop
and think you'd be comfortable.
Hilltop by yourself.
How long if you knew that the
rest of the world was dead,
where the rest of you were like that dude,
remember Ernest Borgnine?
Oh yeah,
the twilight zone.
I remember that.
He was so happy that the exploded cause
he was inside of a vault and he came out
and he's like,
all these books.
I could read these books and he
dropped his glasses and broke them.
Oh know there's a problem.
Yeah.
But he was so excited before that
he was so excited to be alone
with books.
Do you think you could rock it like that?
I could do it for a period of time.
I did it in the Caribbean a lot.
So that was by yourself?
Oh yeah.
That's my line.
Never got fulfilled.
I am by myself.
So what would you do down there?
Oh Man.
Well those first thing,
I started living more outdoors than I
ever did before because I was always a
laboratory scientist.
So it was like by yourself down there.
He didn't have any
interaction with people.
You know I taught a class with,
no,
no.
He got,
when we're talking about like if
you were the last dude on earth,
how long would be able to deal with it?
He's,
I know he's teaching that class.
It's such a,
it's such a big difference.
It'd be like a Tom Hanks castaway thing.
It probably wouldn't last
very long in a good state.
Yeah.
You would commit suicide
and be friends with a ball.
You'd be angry.
You get angry after a while.
Don't you think it probably,
yeah.
I think the human animal,
and that's a fascinating
thing about people,
is that we,
we need each other so much that we get
sad when there's no one else around.
Actually in biological
understanding there,
it's inconceivable.
It's just a quote.
It's inconceivable to think of an
organism ever living by itself.
No organism.
Everlyn isn't it amazing though,
because you definitely
need some alone time.
You know?
Why can't we balance that shit out,
right?
Because you know,
I do like watching TV by myself when
everyone's asleep and I'm alone.
I like it.
If I'm staying at a hotel room,
I'm like,
Ooh,
I get to watch whatever the fuck I want
to watch and no one's going to talk to
me right now.
Like you liked that you liked being alone,
but if ultimately if it stayed that way,
you would be miserable.
You know?
But that's what makes coming
home even even the better.
Yeah,
it's a weird sort of a
pulsating back and forth thing.
Just like everything
seems to be Mr Lipton.
And why is it all go like that?
There's a pull and a push.
There's a,
there's a battle going on right now.
Everything is vibration job.
How do we fix this fucking thing?
Start thinking differently.
You start thinking in a way of let's start
living in harmony with each other and
let go of the stuff that's
easy for you to say that.
What about people with bills and
people live in Shitty neighborhoods.
They just,
pretty soon all that said,
it's going to fall apart.
This is the right,
I really believe we are going
to go into a state of chaos,
not that far into the future.
So my fear factor,
money fucked.
It's no good.
No spend it now.
One of the things you want right now
because it won't be worth anything soon.
Right now the money's not
going to be worth anything.
When do you think money's going to not
going to be worth anything if you cause
that's how we can manipulate it or not.
But I'm saying like how much
time do we have left to buy?
Shit,
seven months.
How much time do you think?
I have no idea,
but it's surprising to me how fast
some of the changes have occurred.
So since like,
uh,
because the,
the book I'm an evolution that I,
that I wrote was what,
uh,
just a couple of years ago and stuff
that I was talking about is now beginning
to manifest already,
especially with like occupy Wall Street,
meaning people are
pulling out of the system.
And that's all it begins.
It's once they start
pulling out critical level,
the system will stop.
Yeah,
but how are they pulling out
of the system by just like us?
They're not,
they're not even being
able to participate.
They can even get a damn job.
How those people eating,
how's that all working people,
community,
community or feeding them
and community is the,
is the necessary step of evolution
and that's what will keep people,
if people
learn to live in community,
they'll always be a support system.
But if they tried to do
it without community,
it's not going to work.
But that's what seems to be going on with
this occupy Wall Street thing is that
there's,
this is the biggest number of people
that are willing to hang out together,
outdoors that I've ever
seen and it has become,
they are United in this like,
uh,
are,
you know Jamie Kilstein,
you remember Jamie Kelsey
or for the podcast?
My buddy,
he's a,
he's an auto every fucking day.
I look at his Twitter,
it's,
you know,
it's pound sign.
Oh,
ws.
Like everything is occupy Wall Street.
Even went to Australia.
We was on vacation over there are working,
I don't know what he was doing,
but he went to occupy Melbourne and
we like to settle the fuck down.
It's not even your country.
You know,
you don't even know
what their argument is.
You know,
maybe you'd be on the
banker side over here,
you know,
I dunno,
I'm just talking shit.
But um,
it's,
it's amazing how much like
it becomes a community.
It really becomes,
you know,
all these people that are
supporting occupy Wall Street,
they're United in this thing and they
feel like they are the only thing that is
going to stop the tyranny there.
The only thing that's going
to step forward and say
enough is enough and that's
hopefully something comes out of it.
But no one knows.
Motion of humanity is community.
It doesn't work if it's not community.
So basically that's the
motivation and look at,
look at the consequence of
this isn't the reason it is.
We have been systematically
deprived of community over time.
At first,
you know,
local neighborhoods.
And then even in a family home when they
put the telephone and televisions in
there and all of a sudden,
uh,
the families not even
working as a community,
it was the last piece of it.
And now all of a sudden there
was no community anywhere.
And that's why.
So you think the television
families watching television,
rob,
some of the community at some point it
did because she's in blocking some of it.
Can you watch like one show?
Oh,
I love it.
I watch it.
I watched the news.
I watch John Stewart.
Yes.
My only tell them 30 rock.
I need to laugh every now and then.
Well,
John's tour,
it's hilarious.
And that,
that shows the perfect example for me
of what up comic can do with just the
regular real news,
the real reality of this
world that we live in,
in especially in,
in,
and do it dress like them.
You know,
where he suits sitting in
front of a death like them.
I just tell him,
just telling the truth has
become humorous at some point,
isn't it?
The way John's tour does it?
Yeah,
yeah.
So,
uh,
so what do you suggest that people do it?
They have to change the way they think.
They have to buy your book.
No,
no,
no.
They have to buy anything
just to work folks.
Delis now it's called the biology
of belief by Bruce Lipton,
phd.
And that's very important,
that phd part because there was
something there at one point.
All right.
That was more than you stupid.
Where'd you go to school?
Uh,
graduate schools,
University of Virginia and was that in
the during the summer of love and all
that crap.
So they,
and,
and so,
so unfortunate because those
would like to see that happen.
Like Hunter Thompson had
that great line about,
you know,
seeing that,
uh,
and then seeing the tide roll back,
you know,
and seeing,
seeing it the one time,
like being in during the 60s and San
Francisco and the acid culture and seeing
what's possible and then
seeing it all pulled back.
Yeah,
it was,
what
is it like to you?
It was the most exciting
time I can experience that.
I have experience on this planet because
every day we get up and we didn't know
what was something was,
we knew something was going to happen
every day cause everybody's like,
it was on the edge.
It was like beginning to burn.
So something was happening.
It wasn't like to mean
to a person who didn't,
you know,
I'm,
I don't,
I'm not that familiar with like what
it felt like when you say like that
something was going to happen.
What was going on?
This was the Vietnam War.
The Vietnam War was going and there
were protests against the war.
The first one was students,
uh,
congregated together against
parents and the community.
Uh,
and uh,
and so there was like occupy Wall Street
with a little bit more anger to it a
little bit more,
you know,
real heavy,
heavy protests going on much more.
Oh,
it was because of the,
yeah,
absolutely.
And at some point is because
people start to wake up and say,
wait,
this is,
you know,
what's this war all about?
There was no reason for the war.
And then was the reason
that the Vietnam War,
who was the real oil oil oil yeah.
And control of the drug trade,
which is part of a CIA thing.
And this was on television.
In fact,
this guy,
Bill Moyers,
one of the best news guys,
cause he was like a real honest guy,
you know,
he had a program on,
that was years ago,
people don't remember.
And it was like a,
it was called the shadow government.
And as you can see it on the web and
it's great because it's play right now,
it's the exact same thing.
And it turned out the CIA was a
funded organization of the government.
It was like on a budget.
Right.
But then they found out that they could
precipitate a war in a place and have
all the local people by
all the guns from them.
But then you say,
well,
yeah,
but the local people in
these places in the jungle,
where the hell did they get all the money?
In fact,
they didn't have any money.
Oh,
what?
They had coke,
morphine,
marijuana.
And so the exchange was not,
and this was on the,
uh,
on bill Moyer show.
He had a CIA guy there say that
they've linked up with the Mafia.
And so this was,
you know,
this is on the show on PBS and they'd
linked up the mafia with what the CIA
would carry the guns to this country,
make money,
sell it to the both sides essentially.
And then because they didn't have money,
they were getting paid in all,
uh,
all this,
you know,
like coke or whatever the hell it was.
And then they'd fly that back in and
CIA planes into the states and then the
mafia would take it from
there and pay him back.
So they got in to a circle.
But the point was this,
they ended up making more money
from the guns and drug trade.
Then the budget,
what was the point?
They need the budget anymore.
They started operating independently.
They were making,
that's what Halliburton and
all this stuff came from.
They started operating independent of
the government because they were making
more money,
creating the wars and,
and,
and getting involved with the drug.
And the gun trade,
and this was,
this was explained to
people and it's like today,
the same issue with me.
It's like,
oh my God,
what are we gonna do about it?
Nothing.
It was just like,
that's the way it is.
And everybody walked away.
He's like,
it's just the same thing today
with these things I hear.
It's like,
what are we gonna do about it?
I'll think,
well,
Micah Rupert,
the guy
who we're talking about,
who's the guy who was a
star of that movie collapse,
you know,
you know when we're talking about he
was a cop and he actually caught them
selling drugs,
uh,
in,
in bad neighborhoods and was told to drop
the whole case and testified about it.
That's why,
that's why marijuana is illegal.
There's more money for the industry.
If it's illegal,
it's legal,
the whole damn thing collapses.
So,
uh,
there's so much money that's
being paid at every level,
of course,
to the police and every other level.
Yeah.
Marijuana is one of my favorites.
The Fed,
the fact that that's illegal
and cigarettes are legal.
Oh,
there you go.
It's logic falls out the window.
Well,
the best evidence whatsoever
that you're being fucked.
Absolutely.
It's more money at it
and making it illegal.
Then legal.
So is there a book you recommend?
Is there a pattern of thinking and he
recommended me and how can people sort of
a wake themselves up out of the state
they're in now and and sort of evolve past
the situation that we're at now together.
Knowledge.
Knowledge is power.
We've got to start looking at the
knowledge that we got to burn.
Also like you have to have an ethic.
You have to have a way of thinking.
Yeah,
and you have to look for the knowledge
because it's not the knowledge you're
going to get in conventional school.
In the conventional textbook
that's selling a program.
We've been playing that program for
years and that's why war after war we all
go,
oh,
another war and other wars like
somebody has been playing us.
It's so beautifully and
it's time it stopped.
It's not working anymore
because they the the the tap,
the system dry.
Now we've got masses of people with,
there's no money for them.
What are you going to do?
That means that you're going
to have a movement of people,
that it's just like the haves and
have nots and there are so imbalanced.
99 one man.
And so eventually,
somehow or another,
it's going to work itself out
probably when the old people die.
And that's one of the best
ways of making the change.
And you notice that just in the last,
I think it was eight years,
six,
eight years,
uh,
the,
um,
survey of people wanting
legal marijuana went from 36%,
uh,
about six or eight years ago.
It's up to 50,
51% right now.
So it says she's in a few years.
You know,
we're the older group that's
got their claws onto the system,
uh,
are dying,
you know,
like,
like Cheney kind of people,
because that's the most
successful way to get rid of it.
But,
but the best thing that's going to happen
is recognizing if you stop playing the
economic game with them,
get out of their game,
they can't survive.
Right?
And so that's why a whole new economy
and a whole new way of communicating in a
whole new way of community is what is
the evolutionary point of disconnect from
the structure and a rebuilding
of something new and better.
How long is this going to take?
A few years.
Not very many,
I'd say within a decade.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's going to happen.
We're going to have a
total new government,
something that was going to be such an
upheaval that something it will not,
it will not be anywhere of what
it is right now within a decade.
Well listen man,
I know you have a a
that you have to catch.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
we're gonna we'll come back cause I
have to talk about some other stuff,
but I want to thank you very much for
coming on the podcast and I want to tell
people to buy your book.
It's called the biology of belief.
Bruce h Lipton,
Phd,
and I'm sure he can get it on Amazon,
right?
[inaudible] g g e d.com.
And there's a great a website mind book,
A.
Dot w s mine book.ws.
And this is yours.
Social networking,
social networking site.
This is yours,
right?
No,
no,
no.
This is another community.
And,
uh,
people,
that are thinking outside the box
and providing information from mine,
Mine Book Dot.
Ws.
Yeah.
And it's just a group of hippies,
essentially.
Yeah.
Hippies.
Thank you very much for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Pause for a minute and we're going to
be back in about 15 minutes after we say
goodbye.